Die Ligatur ist zurück. Wir blicken auf Europas Top-Ligen bei den Männern. Heute schauen wir auf die Premier League mit Uli Hebel, auf die Serie A mit Christian Bernhard, auf die Eredivisie mit Daniel Zander und auf La Liga mit Alex Treuker, jetzt hier im Rasenfunk. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, zweimal Ligatur in einer Woche. Krankheitsbedingt war das der Fall. Ich hoffe, ihr habt schon die Folge zum HSV und zum FCK gehört. Vielen Dank schon mal für das viele positive Feedback, dass da kam. Sebastian Zobel und Nils Bonhoff, ganz tolle Gäste und Eva Lotta, das natürlich super moderiert. Wir wollen jetzt aber sprechen über den europäischen Fußball und dazu begrüße ich mal eine Runde bei mir. Ihr dürft einmal kollektiv Hallo sagen. Hallo. Das hat wie immer ganz fantastisch funktioniert. Aber ich werde nicht aufhören mit dieser Begrüßung. Lasst uns gleich reinspringen. Ich würde sagen, Alex, wenn du magst, dann darfst du mal beginnen. Wir blicken nach Spanien und wir blicken auf Real Madrid, denn die hatten einige Kracher-Spiele jetzt vor der Brust bzw. jetzt hinter sich.
Ja, es war sportlich eine super wichtige Woche für Real, erst mit dem Derby gegen Atletico. Und ich glaube, wir haben es wahrscheinlich alle gesehen, dem Kracher-Spiel gegen Man City, bei dem sie mal wieder in Real Madrid-Manier Real Madrid-Dinge gemacht haben, mit dem späten Sieg in der Nachspielzeit in der 90. Aber nach natürlich einer guten Leistung, also vielleicht dann doch nicht ganz so Real Madrid-Dinge, weil der Sieg war wahrscheinlich eher verdient als viele andere Last-Minute-Siege in der Champions League. Also ja, große wichtige Woche für Real. Die zeigen, abschreiben sollte man sie nie.
Ja gut, aber wer hat sie denn abgeschrieben? Sie waren ja Tabellen-Erster oder habe ich da irgendwas verpasst?
Man sollte sie nicht unterschätzen. Okay, ich formuliere um. Weil sportlich ist das nicht immer die erste Halbzeit Athletico, wer das Spiel gesehen hat oder siehe Phasen gegen Man City. Sie haben halt immer Phasen im Spielen, die mal länger, mal kürzer sein können, in denen sie nicht ganz so überzeugen. Aber es ist Real Madrid, es spielt keine Rolle. In großen Spielen, wenn es darauf ankommt, wissen sie schon, sich zu motivieren oder eben entsprechende Leistung zu bringen, um entsprechende Resultate einzufahren. Und ja, gegen City 4 ab. Ich meine, so wertwirklichen Favoriten gab es nicht. Vielleicht war sogar minimal Real Madrid. Aber dass sie dann im Etihad gewinnen, schon bemerkenswert. Und von daher will ich nur sagen, man sollte sie nicht unterschätzen.
Sagen wir es mal so. Ich meine, in den großen Spielen würde man das ja vielleicht auch nicht tun. Aber kommt das vielleicht daher, dass Real Madrid immer mal wieder die in Anführungszeichen kleinen Spiele versaut, also zum Beispiel gegen Espanol mit Rotation in der Startelf, wo du im Nachhinein dann sehr neumal klug sagen kannst, ja, hättet ihr mal nicht rotiert, dann hättet ihr vielleicht nicht 1-0 verloren.
Ja, ich glaube, Espanol ist eine eigene Geschichte. Da ging es eher so um ein bisschen Unglück, Pech und die Schiedsrichter, die dazu beitrugen, dass das Gegendgebnis vielleicht anders auslief. Darüber sprechen wir wahrscheinlich später dann auch nochmal, die Schiedsrichter-Thematik. Dieses Spiel hat das ja das fast so überkochen gebracht oder wie auch immer man es formulieren möchte. Aber Real Madrid hat quasi den Fokus der Leistung auf die Schiedsrichter gelegt und weniger auf sich selbst und auch das Resultat den Schiedsrichtern quasi zugeschrieben, wie man so formulieren möchte. Aber es war natürlich überraschend, dass sie gegen Espanol den Abstiegskandidaten verlieren und dann auch Tage später gegen Atletico natürlich auch Punkte lassen, wobei ein 1-1 gegen Atletico ja keine Schande ist, es war ja ein Topspiel, aber eben sehr schnell bin weniger Tage in La Liga Punkte wieder verloren und dadurch der komfortable Vorsprung an der Spitze vor etwa Atletico und vor allem vom FC Barcelona direkt wieder geschmolzen. Und das ist so ein bisschen die Story in La Liga, nicht nur von Atletico, von Real, auch von Barca, dass ja ein Vorsprung sehr schnell wieder dahinschmilzt, quasi so schnell wie man gar nicht damit rechnen kann. Bei Real Madrid rechnet man vielleicht noch weniger damit, weil sie ja so unglaublich souverän normalerweise sind und gerade die kleinen Mannschaften ja oft zu schlagen wissen. Bei Barca konnte man Ende November oder Anfang, Mitte November auch nicht damit rechnen, nachdem sie alles im Grunde bodengeschossen haben und dann von, ich weiß gar nicht, sieben Spielen nur zwei gewinnen konnten oder so. Also so irgendwie die Konstanz dieser großen drei, ich glaube ihr hattet es in der letzten Rasenfunk-Folge auch, die ist nicht ganz so, wie man sie erwarten würde und natürlich gilt das auch für Real Madrid. Und deswegen sag ich ja, unterschätzen ist nur so eine Sache. Ich wollte auch darauf hinaus, dass sie ja nicht die Abwehr hatten, wie sie eigentlich ins Rennen gehen sollte gegen Man City. Also komplett improvisiert mit Mittelfeldspielern, die hinten spielen müssen und trotzdem trotz improvisierter Abwehr sogar gewonnen bei Man City. Und das ist eben einfach Real Madrid in der Natsche, wenn es drauf ankommt, wenn es unbedingt sein muss. Sie finden Wege, Spiele zu gewinnen.
Also Asensio und Xumeni standen da in der Innenverteidigung. Ich dachte, da entspannt sich die Lage gerade wieder. David Alaba kehrt zurück, aber haben Sie sich jetzt alle verletzt da hinten drin?
Alaba hatte ja wieder einen Rückschlag. Rüdiger könnte im Rückspiel nächste Woche vielleicht sogar dabei sein gegen City. Hat glaube ich was leichteres, muskuläres gehabt. Weil Verde musste hinten rechts verteidigen, weil Vasquez, der ja auch ein umgeschulter Rechtsverteidiger ist, in Ermangelung an Cavarral, der schwer verletzt ist. Also Vasquez ist auch noch ausgefallen, ich glaube auch muskulär, wenn ich mich täusche. Und so haben quasi zwei Mittelfeldspieler in Valverde und Ciomeni und ein Spieler, der vor wenigen Monaten Wochen noch in der dritten Liga gespielt hat, in Assensior hinten ausgeholt. Und haben das trotzdem nicht so schlecht gemacht. Also man hat ihnen nicht angesehen, dass sie eine improvisierte Defensive hatten. Ich glaube, das war gegen den Ball trotzdem trotz zweier Gegentore ziemlich gut. Von daher, das ist genau das Thema. Man sollte ja meinen, so eine Abwehr gegen Man City im Etihad, das wird knifflig. Es wurde nicht leicht. Aber sie haben mal wieder bewiesen, egal wie die Umstände sind, sie können Spiele gewinnen. Die großen wichtigen vor allem.
Gut, ich meine, es ist natürlich auch das aktuelle Man City. Also das 25-jährige Man City ist nochmal ein anderes, wenn ich mir angucke, wie das 3 zu 2 entsteht. Aber du musst es halt dann auch nutzen und das ist halt dann typisch Real. Findest du denn, dass sich da was im Großen verändert hat bei Real? Ich meine klar, gewisse Spieler wie eben Toni Kroos fehlen. Aber ansonsten, das macht, finde ich manchmal auch schwierig über Madrid zu sprechen, ist, na ist es halt wie immer, in den großen Spielen sind sie da, sie gewinnen die Champions League, haben super Offensive, Defensive unterschätzt man immer, aber sie ist eigentlich auch gut. Ja, gut.
Ja eben, sie finden Wege zu gewinnen, auch wenn sie nicht brillieren, auch wenn sie schwache Phasen haben, also gegen fast alle Mannschaften. Es gibt eine Mannschaft, gegen die finden sie aktuell keine Wege zu gewinnen, weil die das einfach besser ausnutzt, aber die anderen Gegner, ich weiß nicht, ob das auch immer der Respekt ist, die Angst ist vor dem Wappen, vor dem Verein Real Madrid, aber auch bei Man City solltest du doch eigentlich, ja ich weiß, sie sind super angeschlagen, da kann Uli wahrscheinlich eine Stunde drüber reden, aber solltest du ja trotzdem gegen so eine Abwehr zu Hause irgendwie bessere Mittel finden, um dich nicht so dämlich anzustellen. Und dich besser anzustellen, vor allem irgendwie mehr Torchancen herauszuspielen. Und das haben sie nicht hinbekommen. Real hat das gut gemacht, aber es ist wirklich immer da mehr oder weniger immer das gleiche. Sie finden immer wieder Mittel, Vinicius hat glaube ich seit ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Spiele, kein Tor mehr geschossen in La Liga, aber dann wird ihm halt, wenn ihm zwei Assists mehr oder weniger auf ein Silbertablett serviert und der weiß das natürlich zu nutzen. Bellingham mal wieder ein spätes Tor geschossen. Ich glaube, das sein sechstes Tor nach der 85. Wenn nicht sogar nach der 90. Minute zum Sieg oder zum Ausgleich von Real Madrid. Also absolut Klatsch würde man da im US. Sport sagen, aber aus einem Meter über die ins leere Tor schieben. Gut, den Lauf muss man erst mal machen. Also sie finden einfach Wege. Und deswegen ja, es ist immer das Gleiche, was man über sie sagen kann, aber man muss ja auch loben. Wer gewinnt schon solche Spiele so regelmäßig?
Klar, mein ich ja. Aber deswegen ist es halt auch irgendwie so, ich hab jetzt gerade überlegt, in welches Thema man hier noch tiefer reingehen könnte. Aber wir müssen jetzt den Leuten auch nicht erzählen, dass Killian MAP eigentlich ein ganz guter Stürmer ist. Und jetzt auch. Ah, Uli, oh Moment mal, war das nicht unsere Debatte, als der Router bewegt wurde? Schade.
Ja, ich erinnere mich.
Aber ohne Alexi funktioniert das nicht.
Da wurden wir zensiert, sagt er.
Ich wünschte, ich hätte diese Kontrolle, aber es war einfach nur ein simpler Internet-Ausfall. Aber ich fürchte, ohne Alexi Menüş können wir diese Debatte nicht nochmal führen.
Wie war die Geschichte? Er geht gern zum Feiern nach, was war es Stockholm, Uli, oder?
Ja, oder Kopenhagen, eins von beiden. Auf jeden Fall Skandinavien.
Zu den hübschen blonden Frauen wahrscheinlich offenbar. Und lässt sich dadurch ablenken. Ich glaube, das war so die die Geschichte von Alexi.
Das war ein bisschen schärfer formuliert, aber ja.
Was?
Schärfer formuliert?
Dadurch wird er abgelenkt und die Leistung auf dem Platz lassen zu wünschen übrig. Und jetzt, wann war das? Vor zwei Monaten wahrscheinlich haben wir darüber geredet. Jetzt, zwei Monate später kann man sagen, die Leistung auf dem Platz haben sich minimal verbessert. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Reisen eingestellt wurden nach Skandinavien. Das weiß ich nicht. Ja, aber zumindest Kylian Mbappé wird wieder wieder alter, also der gute Mbappé, nicht der lustlose. Das Tor war natürlich Glück, den erwischte mit dem Schienbein.
Ja, der war super. Ich hab das Tor erst in der Wiederholung gesehen, weil ich nur die Schlussphase geguckt habe, was anderes interessiert mich bei Realspielen sowieso nicht. Hinten raus wirds interessant. Und hab dann quasi die Wiederholung gesehen bei der Auswechslung von Mbappé und dachte mir, echt zeigen sie jetzt nochmal bei seiner Auswechslung, wie er eine Riesenchance vergeben hat. Und dann ach so, ach der geht rein, alles klar, gut, danke. Jetzt hab ich das Tor gesehen.
Nee, das Tor war natürlich Glück, ohne wenn und aber. Aber er ist generell in den letzten Monaten richtig, richtig gut unterwegs. Ich versuch grad ein paar Stats jetzt hier on the fly aufzufinden. Also gegen City getroffen, gegen Atletico getroffen. Zuvor dann Ende Januar gegen Salzburg getroffen, gegen Las Palmas Doppelbar, gegen Celta Vigo, gegen Barca getroffen. Also auch in den sieben der letzten fünf Spiele, glaube ich, getroffen mit acht Toren oder so. Also man sieht schon, der ist auch Ende Dezember in vier Spielen in Folge getroffen. Also um es mal kurz zu umreißen und statistisch zu unterlegen, der ist wieder ganz gut drauf. Er hat sich definitiv bei Real Madrid jetzt eingefunden. Er hat ein halbes Jahr gebraucht. Hat das, glaube ich, auch in irgendeinem Interview, ich weiß nicht, ob es Kanal Plus war oder so, recht offen thematisiert, dass er Zeit gebraucht hat, neues Land, neue Sprache, dies, das, neuer Verein. Aber er wirkt schon tatsächlich wieder wie der Weltklasse-Spieler, der vor nicht allzu langer Zeit bei PSG war.
Nicht mehr lustlos und auch nicht mehr lüstern.
Oh.
Jajajajajajajajaj. Vielleicht war der Routerausfall damals, vielleicht war das auch ein wingtes Schicksal, dass diese Diskussion es nicht in den Rasenfunk geschafft hat. Aber gut, also wir halten fest, Real Madrid ist ein ganz okes Team. Ein Punkt Vorsprung auf Atletico, zwei auf Barca. Barca ist natürlich das Team, wo du gemeint hast, gegen die haben sie noch kein Mittel gefunden.
Genau, also ich musste da an, ich will jetzt auch nicht wieder von hier hockt der Barca Typ und er will wieder über Barca reden und sie loben. Da will ich gar nicht in die Schiene reinfahren. Aber ich konnte mich nicht erwehren, Max, als ich Atletico gegen Real Madrid gesehen hab. Und Atletico, man kennt sie ja, die stehen gern ein bisschen tiefer und schalten dann um. Und wie schlecht Atletico in der Zweieinhalbzeiten umgeschaltet hat, wie viele Räume sie hatten und wie schlecht sie die auszunutzen wussten und wie schlecht sie die bespielt haben, wenn man da sich an Barca erinnert, was sie gegen Bayern gemacht haben oder gegen jede andere Mannschaft, die Räume anbietet. Also auch gegen Real Madrid in den beiden Klassikos mit Rafinha, mit Jamal und Co. Wie die in die Räume vorstoßen, wenn die Räume da sind. Das wäre eine andere Geschichte gewesen. Also da gibt es dann schon einen merklichen Qualitätsunterschied, wenn Räume da sind und Real Madrid bietet die häufig an, gegen City war es weniger der Fall. Aber das liegt vielleicht auch an City und an einem Gameplanner auswärts Champions League. Aber in Bernabeu, wenn du da Räume hast, da hat Barca gezeigt, was sie damit anzufangen wissen. Und Atletico wusste das nicht. Also eine andere Mannschaft, die nicht Atletico ist und die auch nicht City ist, weil die eben beieinander sind, wie man in Franken sagt, glaube ich, die hätten das auch nochmal anders auszunutzen gewusst.
Sehr gut. Ja, also da haben jetzt glaube ich alle Hochdeutsch-Sprechenden nur gedacht, dass die nah beieinander liegen. Aber beieinander bedeutet sowas wie runtergespielt, krank. Die sind gerade nicht in Ordnung.
Uli, was ist beieinander im bayerischen Raum?
Scheit beieinander sein.
Wie übersetzt man es denn?
Ich weiß gar nicht. Also nicht in der besten Verfassung sein.
Ja genau, das sag ich ja. Okay gut, wir haben dich verstanden. Danke an die Übersetzungshilfe. Weißt du was Uli, wenn du das Mikro-Ed schon offen hast, dann lass doch auch jetzt auf die Premier League blicken, wenn du magst, beziehungsweise nach England generell. Über was willst du denn sprechen?
Ja, das würde mir fast immer wie immer eigentlich die Wahl lassen. Ich hätte zwei Themen parat. Das eine ist ein eher negativeres, das andere ist ein eher positives. Ich könnte Bournemouth im Zweifel auch beim Anstang Hero irgendwie unterbauen.
Lass uns beide kurz machen, das ist doch cool. Weil Bournemouth interessiert mich auch. Nicht nur weil es eins der wenigen englischen Teams ist, wo ich bei der Aussprache immer so ein bisschen mir nicht sicher bin, ob ich das richtig gemacht hab. Das ist so ein bisschen das, was man in der Ligue 1 die ganze Zeit hat. Hier ist ein bisschen Bournemouth. Hätte ich jetzt probiert. Aber vor allem stehen die ja ganz fantastisch da. Und das haben ja wahrscheinlich auch manche Hörerinnen und manche Hörer auch schon mitbekommen. Siebter Platz, 40 Punkte. Nur ein Punkt hinter Manchester City ist nicht mehr ganz der Referenzmaßstab, bedeutet aber aktuell ein Punkt hinter Platz fünf. Also was ist da los?
Viele, viele, viele positive Dinge. Jetzt haben sie zwar verloren gegen Liverpool in der Premier League, das war dann die erste Niederlage, ich glaube nach elf in Folge, ohne absoluter Vereinsrekord, diese Serie. Insgesamt muss ich echt sagen, Bonnmouth ist, das macht es ja so erstaunlich, wenn man sich mal zurückversetzt in November 23, da war Andoni Ierola schon so gut wie entlassen, hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert die erste Zeit, aber in Wahrheit hat man eigentlich peu à peu gesehen, dass der dem Team genau das beibringt, was er gerne von denen möchte. Und jetzt fast-forward waren sie das beste Team des Landes seit Ende November 2024, wirklich ganz vorne mit dabei, kaum mehr zu besiegen und das Ganze inmitten einer miesen Verletzungsmiserie, die andere Teams auch hatten, aber bei denen hat es halt reingehauen, wie bei Tottenham zum Beispiel, die hatten große, große Probleme, deshalb bei Bonnmouth fehlten sogar mehr Spieler, vielleicht nicht die allerwichtigsten, aber es fehlten insgesamt mehr und das zeigten wir mal umso deutlicher, wie Ierola die Truppe aufgebaut hat. Die spielen inzwischen ohne einen echten, gesunden Stürmer. Die haben Dango Uatara da vorne reingepackt, der zwischenzeitlich mal Wingback links gespielt hat, letzte Saison, ist gar nicht so lange her. Und plötzlich gibt es dann Duo vorne drin mit Antoine Semenyo, der sich unglaublich verbessert gerade von einem wahnsinnig ineffizienten Spieler zu einem Superballcarrier geworden mit fast beidfüßigem Abschluss. Uatara, der die neuner Position plötzlich macht, als hätte er nie was anderes getan, läuft wahnsinnig clever und dann gibt es noch Cloyver, der ganz woanders im Moment ist als er je war. Wenn man sich nur erinnert, zum Beispiel in den Zeiten in Leipzig, wo man gedacht hat, jedes Tripling ist gleich Ballverlust, der ist auf einmal total effizient geworden. Das ist einfach eine Truppe, die gerade großen großen Spaß macht, die eine ganz klare Handschrift trägt, vorne drauf aggressiv und dann sofort in den Abschluss gehen oder aber auch gerne mit langen Bällen operieren. Also es ist eine vergleichsweise, sage ich mal, basic Offensive, aber unglaublich gut gecoacht gegen den Ball. Wahrscheinlich das beste Team des Landes im Moment. Und genau deshalb funktionieren die gerade, wie sie funktionieren. Sie haben zugeben Liverpool, um die Klammer zu schließen, zwar verloren, aber leistungstechnisch wäre es wahrscheinlich unentschieden gewesen. Mindestens.
Aber was ist das für ein Fußball, den Baumeistern spielen lässt? Wenn du sagst, sie sind gegen den Ball das beste Team, ist es dann auf Umschalt spielbedacht? Weil das, was du jetzt gesagt hast zu den Stürmern, das war ja auch viel mit dem Ball, also Ball-Carrier ins dribblings und so weiter.
Ja, mit dem Ball Nachball-Erhalt. Also es ist alles darauf ausgelegt, aggressiv, das wird Alex noch kennen aus Rayo Vallecano, das ist so der klassische Underdog. Die haben die meisten hohen Balleroberungen in der Premier League, im letzten Drittel. Das war auch glaube ich bei Vallecano immer genau das Gleiche. Wenn sie das nicht tun, dann ziehen sie sich zurück, sorgen für Chaos, drücken auf die Außen sozusagen, greifen dann zu und machen es dann entweder mit einem schnellen Ballvortrag, also Carrying ganz klassisch durch die Reihen hindurch oder aber auch gerne mal einen langen Diagonalball. Da haben sie zwei Innenverteidiger, die auch gerne schlagen sollen oder drei sogar, wenn man Cinesi noch dazu zählen würde, der im Moment aber verletzt ist. Sehr junge Innenverteidigung, gerade mit Zerbani, mit Haussen, von dem wir noch sehr viel hören werden, oder aber Kerkäscht, der dann den Ball vorträgt als Außenverteidiger und dann geht es schnell sozusagen nach vorne. Nicht sehr geplant, aber schnell und dann gerne auch mal auf zweite Bälle. Also der erste Ball kann auch ein Exitball sein und dann wieder sozusagen das Gegenpressing forcieren, indem man einen schlampigen Ball spielt, die Abwehr des Gegners sozusagen lockt, dass die denken, sie können jetzt Ball annehmen, rausspielen, zack drauf, hohe Balleroberung, weiter geht's.
Viel Marcelo Bielsa-Liebe sollte man da vielleicht kurz reinwerfen.
Die beiden haben zusammen gearbeitet, also Bira Ola unter ihm, unter Bielsa und das ist kein so großes Geheimnis, dass vieles von den Prinzipien übernommen wurde und er immer noch ein sehr, sehr großer Anhänger ist.
Bei Marcel de Clubos, Bilbao. Genau, Bilbao.
Ja und Prinzipien und Bielsa, das geht ja quasi Hand in Hand. Also Bielsa ist ja der Trainer, der quasi alle Defensivformen, also der quasi das ganze Spiel in mehrere hundert Prinzipien unterteilt hat und danach dann seine Trainings aufbaut. Jetzt ist Bournemouth erst seit 22 behaupten der Premier League, vorher war man noch nie erste Liga, wenn ich es jetzt hier gerade richtig sehe. Achso, ok, wann hab ich das?
Schon mal unter Eddie Howe hochgekommen. Ach, Jahre, na klar.
Ja, ja stimmt, fünf Jahre. Ja, ich bin ja dumm. Genau, ich hab sie übersehen. Aber was würde das denn für Bournemouth, für den Verein bedeuten, wenn man es jetzt irgendwie schafft da oben dran zu bleiben? Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob man über Europapokal da spekulieren sollte, aber insgesamt ist es ja schon mal was ganz anderes, was man gerade hinkriegt.
Ähm, wahnsinnig viel, weil man muss sich mal überlegen, die haben ein Stadion, das knapp über 11.000 fast in der Premier League. Das ist mit Abstand der kleinste Standort der Liga, aber groß im Abstand, das ist ein Dorf sozusagen, inmitten von Londoner Clubs. Und der Besitzer Bill Foley, der seit einiger Zeit da ist, auch ein Amerikaner, wie inzwischen mehr als die Hälfte in der Premier League, der spricht immer vom nächsten Schritt und in der Fangemeinde weiß auch keiner so genau, was das heißen soll. Also einmal infrastrukturelle Fortbildung, das ist einfach, das geht nicht anders, glaube ich, wenn man irgendwas machen möchte noch in der Liga. Aber alle haben immer vermutet, dass Foley damit meint, ah, okay, dann muss es ja jetzt Europapokal-Qualifikation werden. Und das wäre natürlich für so ein Klub, also wenn man Vergleiche in Deutschland ziehen will, ist es wahrscheinlich Hoffenheim, nur halt mit sehr viel mehr gewachsener Tradition. Ist das ein regionales Thema, Bournemouth? Keine Frage, das ist aber generell dieses Südküsten-Thema, da gibt es halt einfach nicht so viele und da teilt sich dann schon auch noch mal der Fußball-Wahnsinn ein bisschen weg vom Rest der Insel. Aber was die Leistung und was das Erreichen betrifft, ist das von einem Club, der vor Jahrzehnten bestenfalls ein Drittlig ist, wäre Wahnsinn. Und das Ganze aber organisch gewachsen. Also das ist nicht so, dass da jetzt ein Geldgeber gekommen ist, der einfach rein knallt, knallt, knallt, knallt, die machen alles mit Augen.
Das heißt, man kann Premier League-Vereine sogar in der Premier League aufholen ohne Investoren. Das ist ja interessant, das merken wir uns mal.
Eine ganz ohne Investor vielleicht nicht zwingend, aber ich glaube, dass fast sämtliche Transaktionen von Bournemouth auch geklappt hätten durch eine gewisse Liga-Zugehörigkeit aufgrund zum Beispiel von TV-Geldern.
Ja.
Okay, das ist dein Positiv. Entschuldigung, Christian.
Darf ich ganz kurz noch, weil Uli ihn kurz genannt hat, der Huysentransfer von Juwe, das war ein Riesens Deal. Also ich glaube da.
Das ist kriminell.
Genau, den haben sie für 15 geholt, nur ganz kurz zur Einordnung. Den wollte Juwe, also Juwe hat halt Geld gebraucht im Sommer für seine Sommerrevolution. Hat sich dadurch von einigen Spielern getrennt, die aus der eigenen Jugend kamen, weil sie die halt einfach zu 100 Prozent, also alles Geld, was sie damit eingenommen haben, konnten sie dann halt sozusagen, geht es ja um diese Abschreibungen, und deswegen wussten eigentlich alle bei Juwe, dass es nicht clever ist, den abzugeben. Den könnten sie heute auch sehr gut brauchen, aber mussten sie halt damals, und ja, stark von Bonn aus, dass sie da einen Zuschlag bekommen haben, weil da waren sehr viele andere auch dran, und ich würde sagen, dass auch Iraola da schon eine große Rolle gespielt hat, weil Häusn hat sich es wirklich aussuchen können. Klar, die Premier League sehr reizvoll, aber ich glaube, da wären auch noch andere davon los, und wir wissen deswegen sehr stark von Bonn aus, und zeigt glaube ich auch, dass sie da auch den richtigen Weg beschritten haben.
Ja, da muss ich auch ganz kurz noch mal einquitschen, denn da eckert sich, weil der KNVB den Verband auch bis heute sich für Spanien entschieden hat und nicht für die Rihande. Da hätten wir auch sehr, sehr gerne gehabt zum Nationalteam. Das ist sehr schade und immer echt Verlusten.
Aber bei den Niederländern ist es auch unfair, was da inzwischen in der Verteidigung rumläuft. Das wäre auch gemein.
Na ja gut, die Frauen haben ja auch ein bisschen Nachwuchs. Das muss ja auch nachlaufen.
Und gönnt halt bitte mal Spanien auch mal einen guten Nationalspieler.
Hallo, wo war sie und wo ist sie? 15 Jahre in Spanien jetzt.
Das wird Wahnsinn. Also das passt natürlich auch perfekt zusammen.
Er hat glaube ich auch gesagt jetzt in einem Interview, dass sein Herz für Spanien schlägt.
Na gut, was soll er sagen?
Er hat sich fürs Herz entschieden, nicht auf sportliche Gründe für Spanien, sondern ich kenne seine genaue im Background gar nicht, muss ich ehrlich dazu sagen, also wie geboren und aufgewachsen und so. Aber er hat sich fürs Herz entschieden.
Nichts anderes erwartet.
Er fühlt sich als Spanier.
Klar, was soll er sagen? Das Wetter ist leider...
Wer ist an ihr das zu judgen?
Nein, nein, nein, natürlich. Du, wenn ich die Möglichkeit hätte für Spanien oder die Niederlande zu spielen, würde ich sagen, ihr habt euch verwellt, aber... Ich verrate jetzt hier aber nicht, für wen ich mich entscheiden würde. Das müsst ihr selber rausfinden. Aber jetzt mal weg von den Positivgeschichten. Jetzt kommen wir noch zu deiner kurzen Negativgeschichte. West Ham wollen wir noch kurz besprechen. Uli, unterseh ich in den letzten sieben Spielen nur einen Sieg gegen Fulham. Ansonsten hat man fünfmal verloren, einmal unentschieden gespielt. Das bedeutet aktuell Rang 16.
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben über Lopeteggi mal gesprochen hier auch vor einiger Zeit, als es zu eskalieren drohte. Ich versuch's mal ganz kurz auf den Punkt zu bringen. Also, die Situation bei Westin war so, dass da ein Besitzer nach wie vor da ist, David Sullivan, der hat sein Geld in der Pornindustrie gemacht, ist inzwischen Mitte 80, hat auch seine Lebensgefährtin jetzt ins Board geholt, die in seinem Schaffen einen erfolgreichen Anteil hatte, allerdings vor der Kamera, und dann weiß man schon ungefähr, wie der Verein geführt wird. Also Sullivan macht, was er gerne tut. Da ist inzwischen ein tschechischer Teilbesitzer mit drin, der gerne etwas progressiver wäre und aufgrund dessen einen Sportdirektor verpflichten wollte, der deutscher war bis zur Transferphase, denn jetzt ist zum Steiten ganz offiziell auch nicht mehr mit da und damit auch der Head of Recruitments, sein Bruder Moritz, die sind alle weg. Und man muss glaube ich über West Ham eines wissen, im Sommer ist David Moyes gegangen, das war schon nicht unbedingt zur Überzeugung von Sullivan, sondern hat sich da eher ganz kurz breitschlagen lassen, dass sie bei West Ham einfach in eine moderne Richtung gehen müssen. Dann gab es verschiedene Trainer-Auswahlmöglichkeiten. Sullivan kannte aber den Großteil der Shortlist nicht und dann wurde es in der Ende Jolene Lopetegui und in dieser Saison ist es eigentlich von vorne bis Ende ein Podius.
Erkannte sie nicht im Sinne von er hat die Liste nicht gesehen oder er kannte nicht die Namen, die drauf standen?
Er hat die Liste gesehen, er kannte die Namen nicht.
Da ist einer drauf.
Englische Uli Hoeneß.
Ja genau, also noch, also 11 Lives. Also kurzum, in diesem Verein wird alles anhand eines Bauchgefühls oder anhand von zwei Berater Ratschlägen gemacht und nichts datenmäßig ausgewertet oder irgendetwas dergleichen, sodass Sullivan immer mal wieder umgefallen ist. Also Steiden hat ein paar sehr positive, wie ich zumindest finde, sehr positive Dinge auf den Weg gebracht. Es hat das Scouting, Recruitment komplett mal sowas wie in 2020er-Regionen geführt, das war vorher zum Teil noch nicht mal mit YouTube Premium, also das kann man mir nicht vorstellen, aber so ist es. Und das ist zumindest mal modernisiert worden. Dann ging es aber so weit eben, dass die ersten Erfolge ausblieben. Dann hat aber der Besitzer aus gewissen Eitelkeiten versucht, die Lopetegi-Idee durchzudrücken. Und dann ist es natürlich klar, wenn sportliches Departement Besitzer nicht auf derselben Linie sind, dann ist ein Fußballclub schwierig zu führen, sodass dann am Ende, glaube ich, also das ist meine ganz persönliche Einschätzung, dem Steiten-Untermstrich sogar froh sein darf, dass er da nicht mehr arbeiten muss, weil ich glaube, so kann man das, ich würde da ungern zur Arbeit gehen wollen, wenn ein Mitte 80-Jähriger dann doch wieder irgendwas anderes macht. Also gab es so, vielleicht nur mal ums zu illustrieren, ganz kurz, das Beispiel, West Ham darf aufgrund der PSA-Regelungen eigentlich kein Cent ausgeben, die hätten dringend, dringend was machen müssen im Winter. Völkruck ist ja andauernd verletzt, das kann man sicherlich Steiten auch zulastenlegen im Übrigen im Transfer und Antonio hatte einen schweren Autounfall rund um Weihnachten, das heißt, von dem müssen wir jetzt erstmal als Fußballspieler gar nicht mehr sprechen, hoffentlich überlebt er das Ganze gut genug. Der ist jetzt glaube ich in eine Sonderklinik gerade geflogen nach Spanien, meine ich und sieht so weit okay aus, von dem was ich weiß. Und jetzt hieß es halt so im Wallroom bei denen, so nennt es die Engländer ja, wenn sie dann zusammensitzen vor der Transferperiode, ja wir müssen was machen, aber wir können halt keine Ablöse zahlen, bitte aggressiv auf dem Leihmarkt sein. Zehn Tage später gibt es ein medial groß aufgepumptes, angebliches Angebot von West Ham für John Duran von Aston Villa, der ja bei Al Nasser dann am Ende gelandet ist. Und die Quinte ist, aus dem sportlichen Team hat es keiner gegeben. Jetzt könnte eins und eins zusammenzählen, wer dieses Angebot gemacht hat. Und wahrscheinlich ist das, also das tippe ich, entweder ist das totale Dummheit oder ist es ein mediales Manöver, um die Fans ruhig zu stellen, denn David Sullivan ist an einem gelegen, er musste Mois gehen lassen, der Europapokalsieger-Trainer, von dem er nie hundertprozentig überzeugt war. Er war nie überzeugt vom Deutschen und schon gar nicht von irgendwelchen Daten im Fußball, sondern seine zwei Berater haben ihn jetzt 20 Jahre lang das Richtige gegeben aus seiner Sicht. Also machen wir so weiter. Und jetzt sind wir wieder beim alten Status. In der Zwischenzeit hat er aber dann Tim Steiten zumindest noch Graham Potter verpflichtet und hat ihnen damit so was wie die Zukunft geebnet. Aber Potter wird da sicherlich auch noch seine Kämpfe haben mit dem Kollegen Sullivan.
Oje, oje. Das hatte ich gar nicht mitbekommen, dass Steiten schon wieder weg ist. Gerade noch den Freunde-Artikel über ihn gelesen, der vor zwei Monaten im Heft war. Ist das schon der Elfreunde-Flug? Klang jetzt nach ein bisschen mehr als nur der Elfreunde-Flug, dass es da zu Ende gegangen ist. Also bei West Ham sind wir fast wieder zurück in alten Zeiten. Du hast es ja schon gesagt. Dann blicken wir mal in die Niederlande. Daniel, was hast du uns denn da mitgebracht? Was ist denn wichtig zu wissen aus der RTV-Team?
Ja, ich hab mitgebracht Ajax-Amsterdam, denn nach über 800 Tagen, so wie man sich immer vorstellt, 800 Tagen, ist Ajax wieder auf Platz 1 in der Tabelle. PSV hat wieder Remis gespielt, mal wieder gegen Willem-Twee Tilburg. Und Ajax hat das sechste Spiel in Folge jetzt gewonnen in der Liga, 2-0 gegen Zidharth. Und da gab es auch kleine deutschen Medien, ein paar Fragestellungen. Ja, warum ist denn Ajax wirklich auf 1 alleinstehend? Die haben 51 Punkte, wie Eindhoven, haben aber auch das schlechtere Torverhältnis. Aber während der Saison zählt in der Eredivisie die Verlustpunkte. Und Ajax hat nun ein Spiel weniger. Die haben noch ein Nachholspiel gegen Deventer. Und die haben ein Spiel weniger verloren als Eindhoven. Und deswegen sind sie aktuell dann doch alleine Katabellenführer. Und das nach ja fast über 800 Tagen. Und da wollte ich mal drauf schauen, wie das eigentlich kommt.
Jetzt verstehe ich auch, warum sie nämlich bei manchen Portalen als Zweiter gelistet werden und nicht als Erster. Aber was bedeutet denn während der Saison, ist es so, also quasi am Ende, wenn es dann um die Frage Meisterschaft ginge, dann würde die Tordifferenz zählen. So zuerst als erstes Kriterium. Okay, alles klar.
Genau, also es geht im Prinzip darum, dass die, ja, jetzt ist die, sie wollen damit versuchen, dass sie die verschiedenen Anzahl an Spielen berücksichtigen, die unterschiedliche Anzahl an Spielen berücksichtigen, weil es doch oft vorkommt, dass Spiele verschoben werden. Also die Eredivisie ist da sehr kulant, was Vereine angeht, die international spielen. Wenn dann Feynord oder Ajax sagen, ja wir bräuchten mal eine Woche Pause, dann bekommen die die auch, zulasten kleinerer Vereine. Die werden dann irgendwann in dem eigentlich sehr vollen Kalender dann nachgeholt. Und da kommt es dann schon mal vor, dass man dann ein Team hat dann 19 Spiele, das andere 21. Deswegen hat man das dann während der Saison so eingeführt, dass die Verlustpunkte dann vor der Torreferenz zählen. Und am Ende, wenn dann idealerweise alle vier in drei Spiele haben, dann haben wir Punkte und Torreferenz, die er zählt. Aber diese Regelung ermöglicht es Ajax zu sagen, wir sind wieder der Bälleinfieber, Herr Leiniger. Ist ja auch was Schönes aus Ajax Sicht. Und das hat mit ein paar Änderungen zu tun und ein paar Sachen zu tun, die Francesco Farioli gemacht hat, von dem ich immer mehr halte eigentlich in der Saison. Er hat in den ersten Spielen, das hab ich ja auch schonmal angerissen, unglaublich viel rotiert. Und zwar nicht, weil er musste wegen Sperren oder Verletzungen, sondern weil er das konnte. Es war für die Gegner eigentlich fast unvorhersehbar, welche Spieler spielen. Da waren fünf, sechs Änderungen der Startelf von Spiel zu Spiel an der Tagesordnung. Das fanden dann einige Spieler auch nicht ganz so toll, aber sie haben zumindest medial öffentlich akzeptiert, dass das so ist. Und es ging auch einigermaßen gut. Also die Ergebnisse wurden dann eingefahren. Es gab dann hier damals eine Nierlage gegen Preda. Es gab damals Unentschieden gegen Deventer. Das heißt, es war jetzt nicht so optimal tatsächlich. Und das hat dann ein bisschen reduziert. Also jetzt in Spielen waren dann immer so ein, zwei Rotationen. Aber es kristallisiert sich langsam auch wirklich bei Farioli so eine Startelf raus und Gerüst auch rauf. Wir haben Taylor und Henderson, die sich im Mittelfeld immer mehr zurechtfinden. Wir haben Ruzo Soto in der Abwehr, da er jetzt Abwehrchef ist. Wir haben Probi, der eigentlich im Sturm immer beginnt. Also das manifestiert sich so ein bisschen und spielt sich so ein bisschen ein. Und durch diese Konstanz in der Startelf denke ich, dass auch diese Konstanz in den Spielen dann auch kommt. Und was sie auch noch haben, das finde ich auch in dieser Weise sehr mutig von Farioli, ist diese defensiven Phasen in seinem System. Also Farioli setzt auf so ein typisches 4-3-3, auf das System in den Niederlanden schlechthin. Und Farioli war Schüler von De Ziavi. Und das merkt man auch an seinem sehr starken Ballbesitzspiel. Also Alaks hat gern den Ball, es sind auch Quoten von 60-70 Prozent, aber in diesem Ballbesitz versuchen sie es auch sehr offensiv zu gestalten. Also hohes Pressing, die Abwehrschritte steht sehr hoch, es gibt viele Läufe in den Sechzzener. Und der Unterschied ist aber zu De Ziavi, dass er extrem defensive Phasen macht. Also gegen den Ball teilweise auch mit einem 5-4-1 verteidigt. Dann kommt doch mal der hohe Ball, der eigentlich gar nicht so angedacht ist. Dann wird doch mal auf Ballbesitz auf gut Deutsch überhaupt nicht geachtet. Und das quittieren die Fans dann durchaus auch mal mit Unmut und Pfiffen, ist aber, Franziske, für Jodi komplett egal. Und das ist aber gerade dieses Risikomanagement, was dann belohnt wird. Alaks hat 18 Gegentore, das sind liegweit die wenigsten, auch weniger als Alpe Svea und Feyenoord. Und das wird belohnt in der Liga. Es ist so ein bisschen das Phrasenschweingeld mit der offensiven Gewinnstattore, mit der defensiven Meisterschaften. Aber vielleicht klappt es diese Saison dann auch mal mit diesem Konzept. Und es ist so ein bisschen, in unserer Oranienfußballgruppe haben wir ja auch gebürtige Niederländer und die sagen, ja es ist ganz gut, dass auch mal einer von außen kommt, der jetzt nicht im niederländischen Fußball aufgewachsen ist, der jetzt nicht diese Arroganz hat zu denken, ja wir müssen dieses offensive System bis zum Ende durchführen. Da hatten wir ja auch in der Bundesliga schon Kandidaten. Und ich mich an Nürnberg mit dem herausragenden Gert-Jan Feilbeek erinnere, der ja auch in Schönheit gestorben ist, bei Nürnberg im Abschließkampf volles Rohr auf seine offensivspielte Gesetze gesetzt, die spielzeitweise funktioniert hat. Und das ist auch bei Peter Bosz in gewissen Phasen so bei PSV, wo man dann auch sieht, dass die defensive Abstimmung einfach nicht so gut ist. Deswegen PSV auch kontinuierlich die Saison dann noch mal ein paar Punkte liegen lässt. Und das ist bei Ajax eben nicht so. Und er hat es wirklich geschafft, Fahrioli dieses offensive System mit so extrem defensiven Spielphasen zu verbinden.
Ja, interessant, weil ich hatte von Ajax vor allem jetzt vor drei Wochen, glaube ich, gehört, als sie in Lettland verloren haben mit 0 zu 1. Und da dachte ich mir so, oh Ajax. Und dann eben kurz danach habe ich dann mitbekommen, also ich habe es vor allem über Peter Bosz quasi mitbekommen, dass die Punkte haben liegen lassen, die unentschieden. Und dass sie jetzt dann doch so gut dastehen. Und Fahrioli ist ja wirklich ein interessanter Trainer. 35 Jahre erst alt. Ich glaube, wir haben auch schon mal hier über ihn gesprochen in der Liga Tour. Scheint mir ein interessanter Charakter zu sein, auf den man mal so ein bisschen achten könnte. Glaubst du denn, dass das also das direkte Duell, das dauert noch ein bisschen, bis es dahin kommt, also gegen PSV wird man Ende März spielen. Das könnte natürlich dann mitentscheidend um die Meisterschaft werden. Aber glaubst du, dass das dann Ajax dazu verhilft, das alles, was man in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren erleben musste, vergessen zu machen?
Tatsächlich ja. Also das Hinspiel im PSV haben sie ja auch gewonnen. Und jetzt haben sie auch gegen Feyenoord echt stark gespielt. Und ich denke, die ganzen Geschichten, es wird ruhiger um Ajax, was eben auch noch ein Pluspunkt ist. Wenn ich mir gerade anschaue, was bei Feyenoord los ist, sie haben ja jetzt auch den Trainer rausgeworfen, Trotz dem 3-0-Sieg, gegenüber Sparta. Und bei Ajax kehrt so ein bisschen Ruhe ein. Also im Winter gab es zum Beispiel auch Gerüchte und den Wechsel von Jordan Henderson, den sie im Mittelfeld eigentlich wirklich brauchen. Und da hat dann auch Fahri Yoli im Vorfeld eines Ligaspiels auch gesagt, nö, der bleibt hier. Und damit war das Thema vom Tisch. Und es sind so Sachen, es kommt einfach eine neue Ruhe rein. Und das ist auch förderlich jetzt endlich für Ajax. Und das sie haben momentan schürfen sie so ein bisschen auf eine Welle. Sie ist es noch keine Riesenwelle, aber die Welle wird auch immer größer. Auch das Spiegel kommt dann zurück gegen Fortuna Sittard. Hatten sie einen Elfmeter bekommen, einen Handelfmeter, über den man auch streiten kann. Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Der ging dann erst nicht rein. Berchrois hat dann fast einen Torhack gehalten. Aber der Nachschuss von Berchrois, der ging dann ins Tor rein. Das sind dann so Sachen, wenn es läuft, dann läuft es. Und sie machen auch auf dem Transfermarkt eine gute Figur. Jetzt haben sie Oliver Edpatzen von Deventa geholt, der ja auch mal mein MVP war. Sie haben offensichtlich zugehört und haben dann Edpatzen verpflichtet. Und insofern, im Gesamtpaket passt das eigentlich ganz gut. Und ich denke, diese Ruhe kommt rein, ja.
Zwei Sätze vielleicht noch zu Faioli aus Italien. Also man kann stark davon ausgehen, dass er in der jüngeren Vergangenheit des öfteren Kontakt mit Herrn Sir Claudio Ranieri hatte. Die Roma ist einer der Kandidaten. Ganz klar für den Sommer Ranieri, der die Roma jetzt ja noch trainiert, aber der ja dann auch in der Entscheidungskommission mit dabei ist, um dann den nächsten Roma-Trainer für den Sommer zu organisieren. Und da ist Faioli einer der Top-Kandidaten im Moment. Also Rencz ist ja von Ajax gerade schon nach Rom gewechselt im Winter, womöglich geht das ein paar Monaten auch ein Rest. Also Faioli wird in Italien logisch auch sehr, sehr gut gesehen. Ich glaube auch gerade der Schritt jetzt zu Ajax spielerisch, das alles, was Daniel schon beschrieben hat, das war ja bei Nizza schon spannend. Aber jetzt glaube ich auch bei Ajax noch mal bei einem Club mit so einem großen Namen, mit so einer Tradition, das tut ihm glaube ich auch gut, in der jungen Phase quasi jetzt diese Erfahrung auch zu machen und dementsprechend sehr, sehr heißer Kandidat für die Roma im Sommer.
Ja, ich hoffe nicht. Aber wie bei Remis und Feyenoord hast du dann auch da recht gehabt.
Immerhin hast du schon etwa zum Netz zu Ajax gebracht, also ist ja alles gut. Und du hast uns ja auch schon erzählt, also als Priske entlassen wurde, als ich das gesehen hab, war ehrlicherweise meine erste Reaktion. Ach jetzt erst, weil du hattest das ja schon erzählt in der letzten Liga Tour. Ja, das wird jetzt bald passieren und so weiter. Und ich will jetzt nicht nochmal den kompletten Schwerpunkt dann nochmal nach erzählen. Also deswegen, du hast ja schon einiges vorhergesagt. Jetzt sind wir mal gespannt, was Christian jetzt vorhergesagt hat, dass es mit Farioli wirklich so kommt. Wir wollen jetzt aber, Christian, wenn wir auf dieser EAA blicken, nicht über die Roma sprechen, sondern wir widmen uns der AC Milan. Was ist da los?
Ja, wir können uns mal um das umgekrempelte Milan, mit dem umgekrempelten Milan beschäftigen. Januar-Transferfenster ist ja in den allermeisten Fällen so, dass man vielleicht ein bisschen noch ein bisschen nachjustiert, ein bisschen schaut, ja, ob man vielleicht Feinheiten ändern kann. Oder man macht es so wie Milan. Man wirft einfach in den letzten Januar-Transfer-Tagen mehr oder weniger sehr viel über den Haufen. Kurz zur Einordnung, das ist wirklich alles in den letzten Januar-Transfer-Tagen passiert. Verlassen haben Milan Morata, also der Mann, der eigentlich im Sommer kam und sozusagen die neuner Problematik lösen sollte. Calabria, der Kapitän, der wirklich mehr oder weniger durch die Hintertür verabschiedet worden zu Bologna. Benassere, einer ja wichtig zentrales Mittelfeld. Und Okafor, der noch an Napoli verliehen wurde. Und es kamen, ja es wurde sehr viel getan, es kamen klingende Namen, angefangen mit Santi Jimenez, das sind wir bei Daniel eben, den Milan jetzt als Neuner, neun Neuner geholt hat von Feyenoord. Es kam Joao Felix, sehr spannend. Es kam Kyle Walker, sehr spannend. Und es kamen auch noch Bondo aus Monza, laufstarker Mittelfeldspieler und Sotil von der Fiorentina, Außenangreifer. Also wirklich eine kleine Winterrevolution. Und das Spannende ist in den letzten Tagen, gerade seit Felix und Jimenez da sind, die haben sofort, die hatten ihren ersten Auftritt in der Coppa gegen die Roma zu Hause in San Siro. Wurden bei der zweiten Hefte eingewechselt und Jimenez bereitet das Tor von João Felix vor, sehr schönes Tor. Also war gleich eine besondere Energie da. Und wie soll man sagen, es gibt bei Milan seit diesen Tagen jetzt, wird schon von den Feb vorgesprochen. Also Jimenez vorne drin, Leao Pulisic auf außen und João Felix so dahinter. Also es zeigt, der Winter hat bei Milan wirklich viel Neues gebracht. Gerade zu Jimenez muss man wirklich sagen, da waren sie lange schon dran, da hätten sie schon gerne vergangenen Sommer das eingetütet, aber da war Fairnought noch nicht bereit, ihn abzugeben. Und deswegen sind sie da drangeblieben und haben das jetzt eben im Winter geschafft, indem sie eben noch Platz geschaffen haben durch die Morata-Abgabe. Und ja, jetzt wird es spannend sein zu sehen, wie Konzessau, die alle jetzt miteinander mischt, jetzt am gestrigen Abend im Hinspiel gegen Fairnought in den Playoffs hat es nicht funktioniert. Da hat er alle vier von Anfang an gebracht. Dadurch ist Reinders auf die Doppel-Sechs zurückge- äh, neben Vorfahna. Also du hast ja Reinders auch noch. Also das offensive, sag ich mal individuelle Potenzial von Milan ist jetzt schon, ist jetzt schon noch mal deutlich stärker, denn Jimenez hat ja Daniel auch schon einiges erzählt. Also ich wirklich glaub, der bringt sehr viel mit. Ich glaub, da hat, in Italien gibt es auch nicht wenige, die meinen, Milan hat sehr, sehr viele Jahre nicht sozusagen so einen vielversprechenden Neuner geholt, in einem so guten jungen Alter, weil logischerweise ist zum Beispiel Giroud war prägend für Milan, gar keine Frage und hätte glaube ich auch niemand gedacht, dass der, dass der so sozusagen diese Leistungen noch mal bringt. Aber bei Giroud war klar, das Ablaufdatum ist halt ein relativ kurzes. Und jetzt hast du mit Jimenez, Milan hat auch Geld in die Hand genommen, 32 Millionen glaube ich ausgegeben und du merkst bei Jimenez, dass es für ihn wirklich jetzt diese Chance auf der großen Bühne, danach hat er gestrebt, das wollte er. Hat auch immer gemeint seine Idole waren Ibrahimovic und Cevchenko. Also da ist schon eine gewisse Bindung auch da zu Milan. Also das ist vielversprechend, auch wenn er jetzt gestern gegen Feonord ein ganz schwieriges Spiel hatte, kaum Aktionen hatte, aber er hat wie gesagt schon getroffen, gleich in der Liga auch gegen Empoli, hat ein Tor vorbereitet. Also ich glaube da kann sich Milan langfristig auf was Gutes freuen. Und Joao Felix ist schon auch sehr spannend. Ich meine wir alle wissen, Uli Weißers, Alex Weißers, das Rauw Felix die letzten Jahre. Ja, das ist logischerweise nicht das war, was sein Talent eigentlich hergibt. Aber auch da finde ich hat man so eine kleine Chemie schon gemerkt. Zum einen er kommt doch in ein portugiesisches kleines Umfeld mit Concesar als Trainer, mit Léo. Ich glaube das tut ihm gut, dass er da den Zuspruch schon mal hat. Sein großes Idol war immer Kaká. Das hat er immer gesagt. Deswegen hat er auch immer gemeint, dass dieses Milan-Ding auch für ihn jetzt vielleicht was ist, was ihm noch mal ein bisschen positive Vibrations gibt. Und in den ersten Spielen hat man schon gesehen, also ich meine das Talent von Joe Felix, glaube ich, da müssen wir jetzt nicht groß reden. Also was der da schon in Halbräumen, was der gedeutet hat, was er eingeleitet hat. Wenn der jetzt, glaube ich, selbst Vertrauen hat, weil er Spielzeit kriegt und die hat er von Anfang an bekommen, glaube ich, ist das schon was, was funktionieren kann. Weil die Chelsea-Zeit, würde ich mal ein bisschen in Klammern setzen, weil ich glaube, dass bei Chelsea in den letzten Jahren viele Spieler nicht funktioniert haben. Ja, das hat die vergrähende Gründe. Ich glaube, das lag nicht immer nur an der individuellen Konstellation der Spieler. Ja, Fußball ist halt manchmal ein bisschen mehr als nur Online-Transfermarkt spielen und dementsprechend hat ja Milan auch das beste Beispiel mit Pulisic, der ja auch im Prinzip bei vielen nicht mehr auf dem Schirm war und seit er in Mailand ist, wunderbar, verlässlich funktioniert. Also dementsprechend glaube ich schon, dass dieser Doppelpack, Joao Felix, Jimenez, Milan schon noch mal deutlich mehr Offensivqualität gibt. Und ja, jetzt geht es halt darum, aus Konzessausicht da quasi die Quadratur des Kreises, die Balance zu finden.
Und dass das alles jetzt so, dass diese Winterrevolution zustande kam, hat wesentlich mit der Tabellensituation wahrscheinlich zu tun, oder? Also sieben Punkte Rückstand sind es aktuell auf die Champions League-Ränge. Wenn man jetzt nur nach Europa guckt, sind es fünf Punkte. Aber vor allem muss man eben erst mal Schritt halten mit den oberen sechs, sage ich jetzt mal, die eben schon so als Block ein bisschen weg sind. Oder woher kommt das? Weil du hast ja auch gesagt, gerade Transferfenster oder Fußball ist mehr als Online-Manager-Spielen. Gerade wenn wir dann über Alvaro Morata sprechen, da haben wir ja erst im Oktober, haben wir da noch drüber gesprochen, als er das Interview gegeben hat, wo er über viele Dinge gesprochen hat, die eben erstmal nicht mit Fußball zu tun haben, sondern über Depressionen, über den Druck in Spanien, über seine Gründe für den Wechsel nach Italien. Also deswegen dahingehend habe ich etwas aufgehäuft, als ich gehört hab, oh der ist jetzt bei Gala, ohne da jetzt irgendwie Näheres zu wissen logischerweise. Aber woher glaubst du kam jetzt der Impuls, das auf diese radikale Art und Weise letztlich auch umzusetzen, innerhalb kürzester Zeit?
Ja, also es war schon ein bisschen Korrektur für den Sommertransfermarkt, weil einfach vieles nicht so funktioniert hat, wie es sich Milan vorgestellt hat und Morata ist da, sage ich mal, das beste Beispiel, also beste unter Anführungszeichen. Ich war auch eigentlich im Sommer davon überzeugt, dass das ein guter Fit sein kann mit Morata, mit seiner Erfahrung, mit Milan, aber irgendwie hat es halt nicht so Klick gemacht. Die Brevovic hat das jetzt auch im Winter bei der Trennung dann gesagt, er meint manchmal, ja, ist schwer zu erklären, manchmal passen dann zwei nicht so zusammen, wie man sich es vorgestellt hat. Morata hat relativ wenig getroffen, aber hat nur fünf Tore geschossen bis Ende Januar, war aber trotzdem, das hatten wir hier ja auch oft, ich finde Morata ist nicht ein Stürmer, den du nur an Toren messen kannst. Der hat ja wahnsinnig viel gearbeitet auch für die Mannschaft. Also du konntest jetzt Morata nicht groß was vorwerfen, aber halt so irgendwie hat es nicht ganz hingehauen und trotzdem kam es dann völlig überraschend. Also wie gesagt, bis vor zwei Tagen, glaube ich, vor Transferschluss war das überhaupt kein Thema und plötzlich kommt diese Nummer, okay, gar leise interessiert und da ging es halt einfach darum, Raum für Jimenez zu schaffen. Also da ging es darum, klar haben sie für Morata jetzt nicht groß Geld bekommen, aber du sparst dir das Gehalt von Morata, das logischerweise ein Bedeutendes ist und da ging es jetzt wirklich darum sozusagen die Millionen zusammen zu kratzen, um Jimenez jetzt eintüten zu können und ja, dementsprechend. A, eine Korrektur für den Sommer, definitiv. Und B, ist Milan schon ein bisschen von dem Paradies, also jetzt Jimenez und Joe Felix passen da ja schon wieder gut rein in diese Strategie von Redbird, also von den amerikanischen Eigentümern, das ja doch relativ jung eingekauft wird bei Milan sozusagen, dass entwicklungsfähige Spieler geholt werden, um dann eventuell ja auch typisch amerikanische Sicht daraus dann halt auch später wieder Geld zu machen. Was da überhaupt nicht reinpasst ist Walker, ganz klar. Aber ich würde sagen, dass Walker trotzdem wahnsinnig gut reinpasst, weil wir hatten es ja auch schon ein paar mal hier angedeutet. Die Milan-Kabine glaube ich ist alles andere als eine einfache. Also wenn du die Léauss und der Hernández hast, die spielerisch, wenn sie top sind, logischerweise top sind, aber A, das nicht regelmäßig abrufen und jetzt was Leadership betrifft, glaube ich nicht unbedingt die Verlässlichsten sind, dann ist, glaube ich, einer Re-Walker genau das, was diese Mannschaft wahnsinnig gut gebrauchen kann. Und das hat man auch in den ersten Spielen gesehen. Er hat ja gleich gegen Inter im Derby debütiert, hat das richtig gut gemacht. Jetzt gestern hat er auch ein sehr schweres Spiel gehabt. Da hat Peixau, der kleine Fairnought, Wirbelwind, der hat ihm da einige Probleme bereitet. Aber ansonsten waren die ersten Auftritte vom Walker auch sehr gut auf dieser rechtsverteidiger Position. Und ich glaube auch, dass der einfach, wie gesagt, diese Leadership mitbringt, diese krasse Siegermentalität, alles mit City gewonnen, was du gewinnen kannst, mit England zweimal im M-Finale gewesen. Also ich glaube, dass das, auch wenn der nicht reinpasst, sag ich mal zur eigentlichen Milan-Transferstruktur, glaube ich, dass Walker da mindestens auf Augenhöhe mit Jimenez und Joe Felix zu nennen ist. Und dementsprechend, finde ich, hat Milan da jetzt im Winter schon mal richtig viel Gutes gemacht. Ein Satz noch zu dir, Max, wo du sagst, ja, sie haben schon die Punkte Rückstand, aber sie haben das Spiel in der Hinterhand noch in der Liga. Also sie sind voll in diesem sehr, sehr knappen Rennen um Platz 4. Das ist wahnsinnig knapp hier mit Lazio, Juve, Fiorentina, Milan, Bologna auch noch. Und da müssen wir nicht drumherum reden. Logisch ist der Mindestanspruch von Milan Champions League wieder nächstes Jahr zu spielen. Gar keine Frage. Aber sie sind da mitten im Rennen. Also das wird einfach ein enges Ding. Und jetzt sind, wie gesagt, jetzt für Konzerstau halt drum, quasi diese Quadratur zu finden. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir die Vier immer gemeinsam sehen werden. Das ist, glaube ich, für die Balance schwierig zu transportieren. Auch rein, dass jetzt auf der Doppel-Sechs, da verliert er einfach viel von seiner Dynamik nach vorne. Und nach hinten ist er schon manchmal mit seiner spielerischen Attitüde auch mal für einen Ballverlust gut. Und das kannst du dir eigentlich mit so vielen Offensiven auch nicht leisten. Also ich glaube, es wird dann eher darum gehen, was wir meistens drei oder vier von denen sehen. Und dann hast du ja noch einen von der Bank, der reinkommen kann, der dir noch mal brutale Qualität bringt. Also das ist jetzt die Aufgabe für Konze Sau. Und logischerweise gleich schon nächste Woche im Rückspiel. Weil das ist auch klar, wenn die jetzt gegen Ferenat ausschleiten sollten, dann wäre das logisch eine riesen Enttäuschung. Da müssen wir gar nicht drumherum reden. Aber da will ich das gestige Spiel noch nicht so hoch hängen, weil das ist jetzt K.O.-Phaser, da geht es halt um Hin- und Rückspiel. Und wenn sie das noch drehen, dann ist alles gut. Und wenn nicht, aber logischerweise, dann können wir da auch eine andere Diskussion führen.
Das werden wir dann zu gegebener Zeit tun. Was wir jetzt tun, ist, dass wir noch mal ein bisschen schneller durch die Ligen springen. Wir haben noch kleinere, kürzere Geschichten. Alex, du darfst gerne mal loslegen, hast jetzt als Längster schweigen müssen. Was wäre denn so eine Personalie oder eine Geschichte aus La Liga, die du noch mittelst?
Ja, eine Personalie ist, die man glaube ich thematisieren sollte, ist der Kollege Anthony aus der Brasilianer, der aus England von Man United geflüchtet ist wahrscheinlich oder abgestoßen wurde, wie man auch immer es formulieren möchte, zu Betis gewechselt ist und da richtig gut funktioniert. Zwei Spiele direkt ein Assist im ersten Spiel, ein Tor im zweiten Spiel. Jetzt wird man denken, ja schön, hast halt ein Tor geschossen. Ja, aber das ist eigentlich eine interessante Geschichte, denn der schießt nicht wirklich Tore bei Man United. Ich hab nachgeschaut, Uli, du kannst das ja eh, du weißt das eher aus dem FF, hat er in eineinhalb Jahren ein Saisontor geschossen und bei Betis nach zwei Spielen schon ein Saisontor. Keine, kein Quatsch, extra nachgeguckt. Das ganze letzte Jahr hat er ein Tor geschossen und in der Hinrunde kein einziges für Man United und kommt zu Betis im ersten Spiel ein Assist und im zweiten Spiel direkt ein Tor. Also er ist eine Personale, die man deswegen mal thematisieren sollte, weil ich schon glaube, dass der Transfer aus sportlichen Gründen Betis sehr gut zu Gesicht steht. Da gibt es natürlich auch eine andere Side-Story, weshalb der Spieler wahrscheinlich nicht der Sympathischste ist. Domestic-Violence-Cases, die ist das. Aber wenn wir uns auf Sportliche konzentrieren möchten, glaube ich, ist das, also erstens musste er von mir in den United weg. Ein bodenloser Transfer, weiß der Daniel auch. Was hat er 100 Millionen, hat er glaube ich gekostet mit Boni. Give or take, als er von Ajax losgeeist wurde. Und man wusste, selbst bei mir in den United wusste man, da ist das Geld nicht wert. Aber die waren halt verzweifelt. Sportlich überhaupt nicht funktioniert, aber ich glaube bei Betis kann er richtig gut funktionieren. Generell steht er gut zu Gesicht. Betis hat enorme Probleme, Tore zu schießen in der Saison. Bisschen mehr als ein Tor pro Schnitt, pro Spiel. Also die brauchen da einfach kreative, offensive Spiele und ich glaube er passt sehr gut zu Spanien. Also zur La Liga mit seinem Spielstile. Besser als in die Premier League und ich glaube er passt auch vom Niveau her eher zu Betis. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja das Niveau von United ist noch weiter unten, wenn man auf die Tabelle blinkt. Ich glaube das macht sportlich gesehen sehr viel Sinn für Betis und dass er so gut startet, ist definitiv eine Erwähnung wert.
Und aber wichtig ist eben auch nochmal darauf hinzuweisen, also da gibt es eben Vorwürfe der häuslichen Gewalt. Seine Ex-Lebensgefährtin hat sich da in einem Interview geäußert, deswegen wurde er auch damals aus der Celle Sao gestrichen. Natürlich geht die Unschuldsvermutung, gleichzeitig geht aber natürlich auch der Fakt, welchen Vorteil sollte die Ex-Lebensgefährtin haben, das in die Welt zu setzen oder was heißt der Fakt? Das ist jetzt eine Meinungsäußerung. Ihr alle wisst, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wie man dem Ganzen begegnen sollte, dementsprechend, ja zwiespältige Sache. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch damit geht, aber als ich gesehen hab, oh der trifft gleich, ich kannte die Statistik jetzt auch nicht von United, bin nicht so tief drin, bei United auch Selbstschutz wahrscheinlich, aber naja, es ist was ganz besonderes.
Uli, können wir ein Lobeshymne zu ihm raushauen, also sportliche Natur?
Ja, Pound for Pound, der schlechteste Deal der Premier League Geschichte.
Das will ich hören, siehste?
Also sorry, ich spreche ja selten in Schwarz und Weiß, was meistens nicht sinnvoll ist, aber ich hab mir das mal überlegt und für jemanden seien es jetzt 100 plus oder minus dann, weil Add-ons wird es nicht gegeben haben bei den Leistungen, vielleicht sind es auch dann nur 90 unterm Strich gewesen, selbst wenn es nur 80 waren, ist das ein absolut mieser Deal, weil das, was du jetzt gerade vorgetragen hast und es gibt da im Übrigen veröffentlicht in Brasilien Videomaterial, wo man das sieht und hört.
Ach Gott, das hab ich gar nicht, okay.
Ich hab wenig Zweifel daran, Unschutzvermutung her oder hin, dass da was war oder ist. Gibt es aber ganz ganz hässliche, da kann man in den Rabbit Hole absteigen, das möchte ich jetzt auch gar nicht weiter machen, aber auch ansonsten gibt es jetzt nicht, also ich hab noch keinen positiven Satz über den Typen, Anthony gehört aus dem Umfeld Manchester United und zwar gar keinen. Um nicht zu sagen, ganz viele anders geartete Sätze, so dass glaube ich, die hoffen einfach nur, dass sie dieses Gehalt irgendwie abladen können.
Also Brazil an Greenwood, wenn man so ein bisschen vergleichen möchte, gerade sportlich, der gleiche Verein, ähnliche gelegene Vorwürfe dann in Spanien untergekommen, weil die Spanier da einfach warum auch immer so sind, wie sie sind, das ist an den Sportliche da ist für uns relevant, der Rest interessiert uns nicht, also moralisch stark zu hinterfragen. Und Greenwood hat bei Retafel auch richtig gut funktioniert, weil sie wie er sich jetzt in Marseille schlägt. Falscher Versprecher, ne? Auf jeden Fall steht Anthony sportlich gesehen, glaube ich bete sehr gut zu Gesicht und ihm steht gut zu Gesicht, nach der Liga gewechselt zu sein, weil ich glaube in die Liga passt er fußballerisch besser mit seinem lastiven Fußballstile, Übersteiger auf dem Bierdeckel ohne Raumgewinn etc. etc. Aber eben betes steht er glaube ich sportlich auch zu gut zu Gesicht und er funktioniert halt auch in den wenigen Spielen, die er bisher gemacht hat. Glaube ich jetzt schon wesentlich besser als bei United und deswegen wollte ich die Thematik mal oder wollte ich die Personale mal erwähnen, weil das für Betis leider Klammer auf Klammer zu wahrscheinlich ein guter Transfer war.
Ja, ich will über positivere Dinge sprechen, über Leute, mit denen man sich einfacher mitfreuen kann. Uli, da hast du uns jemanden mitgebracht.
Ja, ich hab mal wieder gemerkt, dass ich immer noch in alten Schemata denke, den MVP noch nicht so ganz von meinem Herzen habe lösen können, aber macht nichts, dann soll er trotzdem mal erwähnt sein. Hab an der Stelle immer schon mal wieder auch von Premier League Interessierten gehört, dass es gut sein würde mal öfter positiv über Liverpool zu sprechen. Deswegen nehme ich mal stellvertretend einen raus, man könnte vier oder fünf nennen, die unglaubliche Spielzeiten haben, auch wenn es jetzt vielleicht mal nicht ganz so gut die Phase ist für Liverpool, Pokal aus und dann nur in Anführungszeichen unentschieden im letzten Mercyside. Aber Mohamed Salah ist, wenn es mal vor vier, sechs, acht Wochen die Diskussion gab, wer ist denn der wichtigste Spieler der Premier League, der beste, der entscheidendste, der eleganteste, dann hat man vielleicht noch Cole Palmer gegen Mohamed Salah als Duell bringen können. Seit ein paar Wochen ist die Nummer klar. Mohamed Salah wird der Spieler der Saison sein, war nie besser, nie gefährlicher. Ich hab mir das mal so überlegt, ob ich schon mal so eine Evolution gesehen habe. Das ist ja kein Old-Mans-Game, das der spielt, aber seine Old-Mans-Version von sich selbst ist noch mal viel, viel cleverer geworden. Der weiß um seine Gefahr, um seine Anziehungskraft. Dadurch geht er nicht mehr ganz so schnell ins direkte Tripling, ins 1 gegen 1 oder 1 gegen 2, sondern zieht Leute auf sich, öffnet damit Räume für andere. Und die haben genügend Läufer, die haben genügend super cleverer Spieler, die entweder dann nach einer Vorlage was von ihm draus machen, das ist in Anführungszeichen neu. Wenngleich das jetzt auch schon seit ein, eineinhalb, zwei Jahren bei Salah der Fall ist, aber in den Zahlen, so wie er es gerade bringt, ist es halbwegs neu. Und seitlich ist er immer noch logischerweise in der Lage, relativ schnell mit den ersten Schritten aber Gegenspieler rauszunehmen, selbst abzuschließen, das glaube ich, wird er auch nicht mehr verlieren, wirkt wieder so. Also wenn ihr euch mal erinnert an die letzten Tage unter Klopp, als er ausgewechselt worden ist und dann schon ein bisschen gepulvert hat und ja auch immer noch nicht ganz glücklich ist, dass die Vertragssituation immer noch nicht geklärt ist, weil er sich immer noch glaube ich einen längeren Vertrag wünschen würde, wir haben es ja auch schon mal hier besprochen, das Geld scheint gar nicht mehr nur das Problem zu sein, schon auch würde er sich, es geht um Wertschätzung glaube ich unterm Strich im Gegenteil, die hat er sich aus meiner Sicht auch völlig verdient, weil der wird eher besser als schlechter, was erstaunlich ist, bei so einem Spiel hätte man eher das Gegenteil vermutet, aufgrund seiner Schnelligkeitsattribute, aber der Typ ist einfach super gerade.
Aber wirklich 35 Pflichtspiele, 27 Tore, 19 Vorlagen, das sind 46 Torbeteilungen in 35 Spielen, das sind Konsolenwerte, das hat man, wenn man nicht auf Experte gestellt hat oder auf schwierig die Stufe, verrückt.
Ja ganz klar und weil Uli das angesprochen hat, da würde ich auch gerne nur einen Satz dazu sagen, ich finde es nämlich auch, weil man merkt es ihm an, dass er genau diese Wertschätzung, das fehlt ihm. Also ich sitze jetzt nicht mit ihm im Wohnzimmer, aber ich finde man kann das schon so rauslesen, dass ihn das irgendwie tangiert und trotzdem liefert er so ab. Und das ist für mich so die Evolution, wo ich sage, wenn Weltklasse-Sportler sozusagen auf dem Niveau dann abliefern, obwohl nicht alles so ist, wie sie es sich vielleicht gerade wünschen würden, dann würde ich sagen, das ist ein ganz krasses Plus noch mal, weil dass der in einer Mannschaft ist, die funktioniert, das wissen wir. Aber das ist einfach nur herausragend. Also es ist nicht viel mehr dazu zu sagen.
Mosala, guter Spieler, hier habt ihr es zuerst gehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Das ist ein Geheimtipp.
Hört mein Auge auf, den.
Die Geheimtipps, die haben wir ja. Schade, dass ich schon dran war mit meinem Segment, sonst hätte ich jetzt eine schöne Überleitung. Apropos bester Spieler der Welt. Doppelpunkt.
Ach so. Komm, Alex, mach und dann darf Daniel zweimal, komm.
Apropos bester Spieler der Welt, warum sprechen wir eigentlich so wenig über Petri? Wir sprechen wenig über Salah, wir sprechen wenig über Liverpool.
Hat er doch noch seinen Basa untergebracht.
Oh, nämlich.
Von den Statistiken übrigens, da muss ich an Rafinha denken, ich glaub, der hat fast gleiche Statistiken. Ich hab sie jetzt nicht nachgeguckt, aber weil du sie, die grandiosen Statistiken von Salah vorgelesen hat, ich glaub, Rafinha hat sehr, sehr ähnliche Torbeteiligung. Es ist wenn nicht sogar identisch. Ich hab's irgendwo auf Twitter mal aufgeschnappt. Aber ich wollte kurz Pedri loben. Wir hatten ja früher MVP und Anzang Hero. Und ich wollte jetzt keinesfalls Anthony weder als MVP noch als Hero titulieren. Das hätte mir wieder Streb. Deswegen pack ich in beides quasi Pedri rein, weil der Anzang ist und der MVP ist. Für mich der MVP von Barca, für mich der MVP La Ligas, der bestes Mittelfeldspieler in dieser Saison, finde ich in ganz Europa. Und das kommt mir ein bisschen zu kurz, deswegen muss ich hier ein bisschen die Fahne hochhalten, weil sich das in Statistiken nicht niederschlägt. Und das ist das Traurige unserer heutigen Zeit, Max. Alle hauen Statistiken raus, vor allem auf Kurznachrichtendiensten dieser Welt. Und da taugt er halt nicht so auf und dann ja, aber Bellingham schießt immer der 90. immer das Tor und warum ist er nicht der Beste? Ja, schönen Tap-In aus fünf Metern. Okay, das gewinnt ja das Spiel. Aber wie Pedri ein ganzes Spiel von A bis Z beeinflusst. Man schaue sich vielleicht stellvertretend zum Beispiel das Spiel der Sevilla an. Welche Messi-Esken, Xavi-Esken, Iniesta-Esken, wie auch immer Pässe er da spielt über die Kette auf Laminha Mal, der halt, dass ein Torschuss, ein Volley-Schuss halt gehalten wird und dadurch taugt es halt in keiner Statistik auf. Oder es ist halt der vorletzte Pass, wie bei Xavi, bei Iniesta und die tauchen in keinen Statistik auf. Denn wir spielen Fußball, kein Eishockey, da gibt es kein Pre-Assist. Was Petri macht in der Saison ist das Beste, was es in ganz Europa gibt. Und das wollte ich hier mal erwähnen an dieser Stelle, weil das, finde ich, ein bisschen untergeht.
Ja, sehr schön. Und ja, definitiv nicht falsch. Ich meine, jeder, der mal Petri hat spielen sehen, der erfühlt das zumindest so ein bisschen. Du hast so ein Gefühl der Gefahr, wenn du es mit dem gegnerischen Team hältst. Ich mag nur mal an die Europamesserschaft erinnern, da war es so.
Da tauchte er der Welteffentlichkeit so ein bisschen. Menschen, die nicht nur jede Woche Barsche schauen, völlig fairenhaft, taucht er eher auf dem Radar auf, weil da ist man mehr im Fokus, weil er auch autonomal Menschen zuschaut, die eben den Vereinsfußball spezifisch weniger beobachten. Und wir haben quasi wieder den Petri von damals in noch besser. Müsste man Hansi Flick eigentlich mal befragen oder Petri selbst? Zum Einfluss von Hansi Flick würde mich sehr interessieren. Von außen betrachtet, was hat er gemacht? Er hat ihn ein bisschen weiter hintergezogen. Also er spielt quasi in der Doppel-Sechs den offensiveren Part oder den Sechser mit mehr Freiheiten, sodass er quasi Sechser, Achter, Zehner in einem ist und da überall der Maestro auf dem Spielfeld ist und quasi die Fäden zieht, wie man so schön im deutschen Sprachgebrauch sagt und das Spiel beeinflusst mit Tempowechseln. Ballkontakte müsste er im Schnitt 120 pro Spiel haben. Also er ist wirklich der Mastermind des Baser-Spiels. Pressing-resistent wie Busquets zu besten Zeiten, mit einer Übersicht wie Scharvi zu besten Zeiten und mit einer Dribbelstärke wie Iniesta zu besten Zeiten. Also wirklich vereint für mich ohne Witz die drei Spieler in dieser neuen Rolle unter Hansi Flick in diesem angepassten Basersystem und blüht da auf für mich der beste Spieler der Welt aktuell ohne Witz. Ohne Statistik mal die hervorzuheben, weil da werden andere natürlich am Ende in Individual-Awards oben stehen. Salah, Rafinha, zurecht irgendwo.
Aber mit Baserbaes.
Sehe ich nicht so.
Na gut, man kann natürlich auch die These fahren. Also Julian Nagelsmann hat sich eine Hälfte lang vercoacht gegen Spanien. Meiner Meinung nach Pedri war der Grund dafür. Deswegen Can im Mittelfeld, der war auf Pedri abgestellt, damit der keinen Platz bekommt, um seine öffnenden Drehbewegungen zu machen. Gut, wie es funktioniert hat, haben wir gesehen. Im Nachhinein ist natürlich nur der Schiedsrichter schuld. Da sind wir uns eh alle klar. Kann ja nicht sein, dass jemand anders da einen Fehler gemacht hat in dem Spiel. Aber vielleicht war das die Starke von Pedri, die auch dazu geführt hat, wie Nagelsmann da hat spielen lassen. Aber alles weitere, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, könnt ihr in der Folge von Nach dem Spiel damals noch nachholen. Das müssen wir jetzt nicht nochmal aufräumen. Stattdessen blicken wir jetzt endlich auf Daniel. Es tut mir leid, dass ich dich einmal so...
Ja, ich bin ja schuld.
Das Gatta war schon offen, Daniel ist schon raus und dann musste ich nochmal das Lasso rausholen und ihn zurückziehen. Daniel, was hast du uns mitgebracht aus der Eredivisie?
Kein Problem. Ich hab einen wunderbaren Spieler mitgebracht, Ricky van Wolfswinkel. Und Ricky van Wolfswinkel ist schon 36, also auch schon in einem gediegelten Festspieleralter. Aber er hat einen wirklich immensen Wert für Twente Entrelde. Er ist in der Saison eigentlich so ein typischer Backup-Stürmer. Der ist Kapitän, also hat auch in der Mannschaft so verschiedene wichtigen Punkte, wichtige Golde, die er einnimmt, ist dann mehr so der Kabinenspieler, der es war auch im Hintergrund der Mannschaftsgefüge gut harmoniert und er so für die letzten 20, 30 Minuten in Pulse bringt. Nun ist es aber so, dass sich Ende Dezember Sem Lamas, das ist eigentlich der Nummer-1-Stürmer von Twente, verletzt hat. Und sie sind, Twente ist rar gesät, was Sturzstürmer angeht. Sie haben dann noch ein 18-jähriges Talent. Den Namen kennt man vielleicht, das ist Lukas Wennehorf Hesselink. Das ist der Sohn von Jan Wennehorf Hesselink, der, herausragend Name, wie ich finde, spielt bei Twente, 18-jähriges Talent.
Van Wolstwinkel ist aber auch nicht so schlecht, muss man sagen.
Genau. Van Wolstwinkel ist auch nicht so schlecht.
Sendet sei damit auch schon überzogen, mit beiden Namen.
Also und dann ist es so gewesen, dass sich Lammers verletzt hat, das heißt, Van Wolstwinkel musste ran, den gesamten Januar und jetzt auch bis Februar und hat das einfach wirklich gut gemacht. Also er hat die zwei Tore jetzt erzählt in den Spielen, ich glaube vier, fünf Spiele waren es, ist aber auch einfach wichtig als Wandspieler, der einfach auch die Bälle festmacht und verteilt und steht so ein bisschen im Schatten von A. Sam Lammers und aber auch B. Franz Sam Stein, der schon 17 Tore gemacht hat, Sam 20 spielen und bei Twente eigentlich so der, das wäre quasi der MVP bei Twente. Und in dem Schatten befindet sich Van Walswinkel, aber ich würde einfach nur mal ihn Lob reisen, dass er eben auch ein wichtiger Bestandteil von Twente ist und vor allem jetzt bei dem Ausfall von Sam Lammers diese Rolle als Startelfstürmer herausragend ausgefüllt hat und es immer noch drauf hat. Und spannend wird jetzt zu sehen, was passiert, wenn Sam Lammers wieder fit ist. Also ich denke nicht, dass Lammers dann lange auf der Bank sein wird. Ich denke, dass Van Walswinkel dann auch ohne zu lamentieren, dann wieder auf die Bank gehen wird. Aber mal gucken, er hätte sich auf jeden Fall mehr Spielzeit verdient, würde ich sagen. Und das ist eine kleine Geschichte. Und dann wollte ich jetzt auch noch eine andere Geschichte erzählen, weil das ist ja wieder unfassbar eigentlich. Denn vor zwei Wochen war es so, dass in dem Spiel Herrn Fehn gegen Fortuna Sittard gab es dann doch einen Fall für die Schiedsrichter und einen Fall für den Liga-Verband. Es war in der 88. Minute beim Standverband 2 zu 1 für Herrn Fehn der Fall, dass Sittard doppelt wechseln wollte. Und es kamen auch zwei Spiele aufs Feld, aber nur einer ging runter. Das heißt, die waren tatsächlich für fast eine halbe Minute mit zwölf Mann unterwegs. Und genau in dieser Spielphase, wo Sittard mit zwölf Mann unterwegs war, gab es einen Einwurf, der ausgeholt wurde, mit diesen zwölf Spielern. Und erst dann ist es nochmal aufgefallen, der Spieler ging runter und dann wurde es mit 11 gegen 11 vorgesetzt. Aber natürlich, aus dem Einwurf gab es eine Ecke. Und aus der Ecke resultierte das 2-2, der auch das Endstand war. Und dann gab es natürlich einen großen Aufschrei. Und jetzt, die vorgestern, hat der Verband entschieden, ja es bleibt alles so wie es ist. Das 2-2 hat Bestand. Und als Grund wird angeführt, dass dieser Einwurf ab damit 11 gespielt wurde und dass der Fehler einen nicht-sektifikanten Einfluss haben soll auf das Endergebnis. Das heißt, ist so ein bisschen die Kategorie Glücksfilz der Woche. Das hat sich das 2-2 noch bestand. Bei Sitzart, ja.
Das ist so unglaublich. Ich weiß noch, ich hab das mitbekommen, weil im Rasenfunk Discord, in Offiziellen, da hat das jemand gepostet mit hier, sag mir mal, welche Formation das ist. Und da dachte ich mir, das ist so typisch Rasenfunk, dass die jetzt hier die Formation von Fortuna Sitzart aufdröseln, weil die wahrscheinlich irgendwas ganz Tolles machen. Und dann hab ich gezählt und hab gesehen, ah, das ist das berühmte Chelsea 443, das wir schon seit einer ganzen Weile nicht mehr gesehen haben. Und ja, aber es ist ja irre, dass das dann trotzdem zählt. Obwohl es ja so ein eindeutiger, na gut. Aber ja, sehr schön, haben wir das hier auch noch abgedeckt. Das ist ja fast schon wieder untergegangen. Dann hatten wir jetzt zwei Geschichten aus der Ehre die Wiese. Weißt du was, Christian? Dann hau jetzt auch zwei Geschichten raus. Heute ist einfach die wilde Ligatur.
Wow. Ja, jetzt bis auf die Schiedsrichtergeschichte gerade von Daniel, habt ihr ja so viele schöne Geschichten gehabt, so viel Positives. Dann crash ich das jetzt mal mit ein bisschen was ziemlich Enttäuschenden und komm mit Monza ums Eck und zwar dem Niedergang von Monza. Vielleicht erinnerst du dich noch ein paar vor relativ kurzer Zeit. Monza erstmaligst in der Clubgeschichte aufgestiegen. Berlusconi als Eigentümer, Gagliani als Manager. Und dann war ja schon so ein bisschen die Frage, weil die da auch sehr viel investiert haben. Ja, war klar. Eigentlich war die Idee, dass die dann relativ schnell auch auf die linke Tabellenhälfte rüberwandern quasi, also das Ganze eher nach oben interpretieren. Ja, jetzt schauen wir uns die aktuelle Tabelle an. Monza ist mit Abstand letzter, hat von 24 Saisonspielen zwei gewonnen, hat 13 Punkte geholt aus 24 Spielen. Ist im Prinzip, kann man sagen, nach der Hinrunde fast schon abgestiegen. Sie haben acht Punkte Rückstand auf den ersten Nicht-Abstiegsplatz. Und wie gesagt, mit 13 Punkten aus 24 Spielen kann man sich ja mal ausrechnen, was da acht Punkte bedeuten. Und deswegen ist schon mal spannend, kurz mal drauf auf, drauf zu schauen, was da passiert ist eigentlich. Und da müssen wir anfangen mit, ja, das Silvio Berlusconi ist ja gestorben mittlerweile und seit er eben nicht mehr da ist, ja, ist da halt vieles weggebrochen. Seine Söhne, seine Töchter haben relativ schnell klargemacht, dass das finanzielle Engagement, das der Vater noch geleistet hat, eben nicht mehr fortgesetzt wird. Und ja, und jetzt haben wir die Situation, dass schon im vergangenen Sommer haben sie die Gregorio an Juve abgegeben, Torhüter Colpani an die Fiorentina, Carlos Augusto, der mittlerweile eine wichtige Rolle bei Inter spielt. Also man sieht, da waren viele Spieler da, mit denen ja eigentlich hätte weiter der Weg beschritten werden sollen. Die sind jetzt alle abgegeben worden. Mit Palladino, einer der spannendsten Trainer, mittlerweile bei der Fiorentina, haben wir ja auch schon darüber gesprochen, hast du den Erfolgstrainer im Sommer verloren. Und jetzt ist es so und deswegen fand ich passt das jetzt so wunderbar. Jetzt haben eigentlich, siehst du die Resignation, die sie eigentlich schon da haben, siehst du auch in den letzten Transfer-Tagen im Januar, jetzt haben sie nur mal mehr oder weniger das letzte Tafelsilber, das sie haben, haben sie auf den Transfermarkt auch gebracht. Sie haben Maldini, ein Atalanta abgegeben, das war sicherlich der spannendste Spieler, der Sohn von Paolo Maldini. Sie haben Bondo eben, den laufstarken Mittelfeldspieler, an Milan abgegeben. Sie haben Juric, den Neuner abgegeben. Und im Prinzip also ist es ein Eingeständnis, dass die eigentlich wissen, dass jetzt alles schon Richtung Serie B geht. Also die probieren sozusagen im laufenden Betrieb, sich aufzustellen für die nächste Saison. Dazu passt das jetzt mit Nesta. Alessandro Nesta hat auch den Trainer zurückgeholt, den sie vor eineinhalb Monaten gefeuert haben, weil Boquete, der Nachfolger von zwölf Spielen, elf verloren hat. Und jetzt holst du dir Nesta halt eben wieder zurück, was auch meiner Meinung nach dahin schon deutet auf nächstes Jahr, weil Nesta eben die letzten Jahre in der Serie B getrainiert hat, viel Erfahrung da hat. Und das sind eben alles so Zeichen, dass eigentlich bei innen Monza, bei Gagliani klar ist sozusagen. Das Kapitel Serie A ist jetzt erstmal vorbei und jetzt probieren sie sich so ein bisschen zu erneuern. Schon im laufenden Betrieb haben jetzt zum Beispiel im Winter mit Zerolli ein großes Talent von Milan ausgeliehen. Gagliani lässt ja logischerweise seine Connections spielen. An Camarda waren sie auch dran von Milan, denn das große Sturmtalent, das haben sie am Ende nicht bekommen. Aber es geht jetzt einfach darum, da im Sommer in der Serie B wieder anzugreifen. Aber schon krass eben, wie schnell dann halt auch so ein Abstieg passieren kann. Ein Satz noch dazu war jetzt nicht nur Verkäufe, sondern auch Matteo Pesina. Das war so ein bisschen das Gesicht dieses neuen Monsters, den haben sie ja von Atalanta geholt als Nationalspieler. Also es war quasi ein Zeichen der Stärke zu sagen, schaut mal her Monster, wir sind jetzt da, wir wollen da auch mitmischen. Gebürtiger Mann aus Monster, also der sollte auch das Gesicht werden und der fehlt jetzt zum Beispiel in dieser Spielzeit wahnsinnig viel verletzt. Das tut ihnen halt einfach weh, weil sie eben viel andere Qualität verloren haben. Ja und jetzt geht's eigentlich straighten Weges Richtung CRB. Mal schauen, was dann nächsten Sommer passiert.
Und wenn wir bei Transfers sind, dann können wir auch noch über dein zweites Thema sprechen, was du noch mitgebracht hast. Denn wer auch nur irgendwie mitverfolgt hat, was Como so gemacht hat, bei dem ist das Wort Transfer hängen geblieben.
Ja, Uli kann schon zurecht grinsen. Da ist es einfach wahnsinnig spannend bei Como. Kurz zur Einordnung, Como wird ja von Fabregas trainiert, ist auch aufgestiegen, aber ist halt alles andere als ein normaler Aufsteiger, weil die wahnsinnig viel finanzielle Power in der Hinterhand haben. Das sind die Eigentümer, das sind die Gebrüder Hartono, das ist eine indonesische Brüderfamilie. Die sind mehrere Milliarden Dollar schwer. Also die spielen wirklich im ganz, ganz großen Game mit, was die finanziellen Möglichkeiten betrifft. Ja, und kommen wir jetzt einfach mal zwischen Sommer-Transferfenster plus jetzt Winter-Transferfenster geschmeidige 100 Millionen ausgegeben für einen Aufsteiger. Dazu muss man sagen, auch jeweils 50-50. Also die haben jetzt auch im Winter einfach nochmal 50 Millionen nachgelegt. Und das Spannende ist, da ist viel Aktionismus, klar. Aber das sind auch sehr viele interessante, spannende Leute, weil sie junge Leute kaufen, weil Fabregast da ein Riesenanker einfach ist, ein Magnet, der da Connections gerade nach Spanien hat, talentierte Leute halt. Der hat jetzt zum Beispiel von Betis Assane Diou geholt, den kennt Alex sicher, haben sie einfach mal 14 Millionen hingelegt. Carre, haben sie aus Lyon geholt für 15 Millionen. Duvikas von Celta für 14 Millionen Stürmer. Also da kommen viele spannende Leute, entwicklungsfähige Leute. Es hieß sogar, dass es im Winter ein Angebot an Theo Hernandez gab. Also nur mal zu verdeutlichen, in welchen Sphären da Cormo halt auch quasi vorzudringen gilt. Denn das, was für Monster gilt, diese Möglichkeiten weit nach oben zu kommen, die ist bei Cormo definitiv auch da. Also der Plan ist ganz klar, sozusagen da die nächsten Jahre auch, ja wie soll man sagen, andere fußballerische Sphären anzugreifen. Und dementsprechend ist es wahnsinnig spannend. Das ist wahnsinnig spannend, weil Fabregas genau den Fußball spielen lässt, glaube ich, den man mit dem Spieler Fabregas verknöpfen würde. Ich meine, über Fabregas muss man auch nicht viel sagen, was der für ein Spieler war. Und genauso möchte er Fußball spielen, das ist ein sehr dominanter Ansatz, Ballbesitzansatz, riskanter Ansatz, der dazu führt, dass Cormo eigentlich gerade gegen die Guten immer richtig gut aussieht, weil die einfachen, feinen Ballspielen haben zum Beispiel, was Abschlüsse betrifft, sind die Statistik in der Liga, glaube ich, Platz vier. Also die haben mehr Abschlüsse als Napoli, mehr Abschlüsse als Milan, mehr Abschlüsse als Juve. Also das ist eine Mannschaft, die über Sport, die über Ballbesitz und Dominanz kommt, aber sie steckt halt trotzdem mittendrin im Abstiegskampf, haben jetzt gegen Milan, Inter und Juve immer gut ausgeschaut, aber knapp verloren. Und dementsprechend gilt es da jetzt, die Balance zu finden, aus mit talentierten Jungs diesen Fabregas-Fußball zu spielen, aber halt trotzdem jetzt erstmal die Klasse zu halten, denn darum geht's. Und dann bin ich mir sicher, dass die nächsten Sommer wahrscheinlich noch mal anders angreifen werden auf dem Transfermarkt. Also sehr spannendes Projekt. Ich glaube auch, dass sie drin bleiben, weil es einfach viel zu viel... Ja, das glaube ich ist erster Anfang bei denen, weil die, wie gesagt, Fabregas, das sind ja auch Ori und Dennis Weiss, sind ja auch Miteigentümer. Also die haben schon, die haben schon noch viel größere Pläne und dementsprechend sehr, sehr spannendes Projekt.
Eric Garcia von FC Barcelona wollten sie ja auch im Winter holen und da gab es offenbar auch schon eine Übereinkunft und dann hat Hansi Flix ein Veto eingereicht.
Also diese...
Sie haben auch viel günstiges Geld, ich glaube sieben bis zehn Millionen oder so bekommen.
Ja, also gerade diese Verbindungen, die Fabregas nach Spanien hat, die sind halt Gold wert. Also der erholt sich da wirklich Leute so ein Diao und so. Also da waren auch ganz andere dran, aber da zieht halt Fabregas dann auch und das ist schon, das ist schon sehr spannend. Also wie gesagt, ich gehe fest davon aus, dass wenn die drin bleiben und ich glaube, die bleiben drin, weil die einfach viel zu viel Qualität haben im Vergleich zu der restlichen Konkurrenz da hinten drin, dann holen die glaube ich im Sommer noch mal anders aus.
Ihr Stadion werden sie auch modernisieren in den nächsten Jahren hab ich gesehen. So gab es ein neues Stadionmodell. Also die haben einiges vor auf meinem Koma.
Aber Christian, du hast ja vor ein paar mal gesagt, Fußball ist nicht Manager spielen oder Konsolen spielen. In dem Fall schon ein bisschen. Ja, absolut. Ein kleines bisschen.
Du hast völlig recht. Absolut. Also es ist, man kann es auch als aktionistisch betiteln. Definitiv. Ich will es auch nicht zu positiv frameen, weil es ist, hallo, nochmal klar, 100 Millionen für einen Aufsteiger und was da alles kommt. Ich sage nur, was spannend ist, dass halt viel Junges kommt und viel Entwicklungsfähiges. Also die holen jetzt nicht. Es war ja damals diese Dingnummer im Sommer, die überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat. Ah, mit Varan. Das war so eine Nummer, würde ich sagen, oh mein Gott. Wenn ihr mehr von den Nummern macht, dann fährt ihr das Ding an die Wand. Aber die Leute, die sie halt mittlerweile holen, die haben schon großes Potenzial. Aber ja, es ist, gebe ich dir völlig recht, es ist logisch ein bisschen.
Ich glaube immer noch, das haben wir auch schon mal ganz kurz bei RONDO TV besprochen, Tony Blum hat da ja auch seine Finger drin, der bei Brighton ja der Besitzer und auch Datenmann ist. Ich weiß das nicht, das ist nur eine Vermutung, ich versuch das rauszufinden irgendwann mal. Ich hab immer noch das Gefühl, die probieren da irgendwelche Zusammensetzungen von irgendwelchen Algorithmen aus. Wie kriegst du sonst KEMF und VARAN zusammen in einer Transferperiode?
Das ist ja sowieso der größte Fehler, den ich gemacht habe, hier als Moderator, dass ich nicht den alten Sportjournalisten diese Unsitte zu machen, dass ich nicht gesagt hab, was ist bei Marc-Oliver KEMF und Yannick Engelhardt's KOMO los? So hätte ich es natürlich anmoderieren müssen. Völlig liegen gelassen.
Dieser Deutsche spielt unter einer Legende.
Genau. Das ist dann die Weite.
Das klingt aber nach Online-Journalismus dann. Das ist eine Clickbait-Überschrift bei Anschlägen, Portalen, dann Ulli.
Wie soll ich dir jetzt sagen, wo Podcasts veröffentlicht werden? Das machen wir nach der Sendung. Wir machen noch eine Quick-Runde bzw. Ulli darf jetzt noch schnell sein zweites Thema und leg gleich dein drittes hinterher und dann gehen wir jetzt noch schnell durch.
Streng genommen hab ich ja eh schon zwei gebracht.
Da siehst du sehr gut.
Aber wie ihr wollt, ich hab noch oder hätte noch mitgebracht, einfach nur noch mal in einem alten Moment zu denken, umfasst aber auch ganz gut, dass bei Everton sich was rührt. Die haben David Moyes zurückverpflichtet. Das kann man jetzt entweder als Feel-good-Story nehmen oder aber einfach nur, wenn man eingefroren wäre, zwölf Jahre lang hätte nichts mitbekommen, dann wärs auch so wie es immer war. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, die spielen wieder gut, die schießen plötzlich Tore, die haben gestern dann gegen Liverpool sogar noch hinten raus, 90 plus 8 glaube ich war es dann am Ende ausgeglichen, 2 zu 2. Das letzte Mercy Side Derby im Goodison Park, den ich sehr, sehr, sehr vermissen werde, muss ich sagen, zeigt zum einen, dass die Meisterschaft theoretisch noch mal spannend werden könnte. Also ich glaube das zwar nicht, aber es sind in Anfangsreihen nur noch plus 7. Jetzt haben wir ja gleich auf, was die gespielten Spiele betrifft bei Liverpool. Arsenal wird aber wahrscheinlich ohne Harvards diese Saison zu Ende spielen müssen. Das heißt, könnte sich rechnen, dass die nichts gemacht haben im Winter. Die hätten ja nur dann was gemacht, wenn sie total überzeugt gewesen wären. Bei Everton bin ich mir inzwischen sicher, dass die die Klasse halten werden. Mal wieder. Es geht einfach, sie versuchen alles, aber sie steigen einfach nie ab. Und wenn man irgendwie noch mal Zeit hat, kriegt man glaube ich in sozialen Netzwerken ganz gut abgegriffen. Dann schaue man sich nochmal die letzten Szenen dieses Derbys an, weil ein sogenanntes Friendly Derby war es dann nicht mehr. Einige Platzverweise und dieses 90 plus 8. Umfassend für, ich hätte in der Periode vom letzten Rasenfunk Liga Tour, Aufnahmezeitpunkt bis hin zu dem 580 Themen mitbringen können, weil es so viel passiert ist, nicht immer so. Aber in dem Fall ist es wirklich so, diese Liga lebt gerade wieder. All die Klischees super aus.
Sollte man vielleicht Click and Rush hören, aber das wissen ja die Hörerinnen und Hörer sowieso schon, dass das der Weg ist, noch umfassender informiert zu werden. Wir haben noch ein ganz klitzekleines Thema aus der Liga. Alex, du hast gesagt, du kriegst das kurz hin. Ich bin gespannt.
Ich gebe mir Mühe es kurz zu machen. Ja, weil wir besprechen ja hier immer auch über das, was so die Liga beschäftigt und die Themen, die man vielleicht nur am Rande mitbekommt oder teilweise gar nicht mitbekommt. Und dass wir die dann besprechen. Deswegen ist es tatsächlich notwendig, sage ich mal, über die Schiedsrichter-Affäre zu sprechen oder den Schiedsrichter-Streit quasi in La Liga, weil wir es vorhin ganz kurz thematisiert hatten. Real Madrid hat bei Espanyol 1 zu 0 verloren und hat unglücklich verloren. Und sie geben dem Schiedsrichter die Schuld, denn Romero, das war der Torschütze in der, ich glaube 86. zum 1 zu 0, der hätte nicht mehr auf dem Platz stehen dürfen, weil Kilian Wappé von hinten wirklich brutal umgesenzt hat. Und der Schiedsrichter gab keine rote Karte, der war blieb still, was wahrscheinlich der größere Skandal ist oder die größere Fehlentscheidung, dass der war und nicht sagt, guck dir das an, das ist eigentlich rot. Und ja, und weil eben Justas der Torschütze war und er hätte wirklich rot sehen müssen, da gibt es keine zwei Meinungen. Hat Real Madrid infolgedessen einen Schiedsrichter-Brandbrief quasi an verschiedene Institutionen geschickt, hat sich also heftig über das Schiedsrichterwesen in La Liga beschwert und das war ziemlich, ziemlich heftig. Also da stand ich, ich hab sie jetzt mal vor mir, ich zitiere nur, in diesem Brandbrief und in diesem Beschwerdebrief war von Wettbewerbsverzerrung, Betrug, Manipulation, die Rede und dieses Spiel bei Espanol, also diese Fehlentscheidung, diese nicht rote Karte sei der Höhepunkt eines komplett heruntergekommenen Schiedsrichtersystems gewesen. Ein System, das, Zitat, systematisch korrupt sei und darauf bedacht, sich selbst zu schützen. Also ein Rundumschlag von Real Madrid, ein öffentlich gemachte in einem öffentlichen Schreiben. Und ja, ist natürlich dann ein ziemlich großes Thema und darauf hat La Liga jetzt reagiert logischerweise und vor der Disziplinar-Kommission des Verbandes RFEF Anzeige erstattet. Also da geht es dann in irgendwelche legalen Geschichten rein, dass man da quasi jetzt auf institutioneller Ebene, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht irgendwelche Beschwerden...
Ausgerechnet Real Madrid.
Ich wollte es nicht so sagen, Nils, aber Nils sag ich schon. Nils hätte aufgepasst, ausgerechnet Real Madrid. Der muss mich immer verkneifen, so was zu sagen.
Ich mein, Basa hat da ja auch seine Vorgeschichte, aber bei Real hatten wir ja im Oktober diese wunderbare Geschichte, dass ein Ex-Schiedsrichter zugeschaltet ist in einer TV-Sendung und dessen Papagei fängt auf einmal im Hintergrund an, die Hymne von Real Madrid zu pfeifen.
Ja, also es ist ein Riesenthema, ich wollte es kurz machen, ich galoppiere ein bisschen durch. Sie haben jetzt natürlich auch einen Elfmeter gegen sich bekommen, gegen Atletico und dann ist natürlich der Aufschrei enorm, weil jetzt darf ja nichts mehr Elfmeter sein. Der war auch ein bisschen zwielichtig, also ich hätte ihn nicht gegeben, sag ich auch ehrlich, aber er ist jetzt nicht komplett falsch. Auf jeden Fall fühlen sie sich natürlich etwas bedrogen jetzt. Und das ist dann ein bisschen unglücklich, wenn das ausgerechnet Real Madrid ist, denn die Statistik in La Liga ist, das war der erste Elfmeter in der ganzen Saison gegen Real Madrid und sie haben 20 glaube ich für sich bekommen, also ein Plus Minus von 19 und die nächste Mannschaft ist Barca mit Plus Minus 7 oder irgendwie sowas. Also es passt nicht ganz in den Zeitgeist, dass sie sich so benachteiligt fühlen, aber sie sprechen natürlich was nicht zwingend Falsches an, denn die Schiedsrichter sind sehr, sehr schwach in La Liga. Nur, und das ist jetzt das Thema, machen die das absichtlich? Also ist das wirklich Manipulation und systematische Korruption oder sind die einfach nur bodenlos schwach? Ich würde zur Letzteren zendieren, man kennt es ja in der Bundesliga auch, das sind viele Entscheidungen, die kann man nicht verstehen oder die kann man so oder so auslegen und sie werden aber in jedem Spieltag anders entschieden. Also mal gibt's für von hinten in die Beine rot durch den wahr, weil der Schier ist nicht sieht und mal gibt es das nicht eine Woche später und mal schaltet sich der wahr nicht ein und mal schaltet er sich ein und das ist wirklich ein Thema, da hat er einmal in der Sache wahrscheinlich recht oder in der Beschwerdesache, dass die Schiedsrichterei nicht gut ist. Also auch in den letzten drei Wochen, vier Wochen gab es Entscheidungen, rote Karten hier und keine rote Karte da. Man kann das nicht verstehen. Es ist wirklich, du würfelst quasi die Entscheidung und das ist schwierig, aber quasi so ein Brief so zu formulieren ist eine andere Qualität. Und die Eskalationsstufe ist schon bemerkenswert hoch.
Du hast es viel diplomatischer formuliert.
Genau. Und das ist ja, also direkt gewürfelt wird ja vielleicht nicht. Und aber alle, die sich über DFB-Schiedsrichter beschweren, ich möchte nicht sagen, dass das komplett aus der Luft gegriffen sei, sich manchmal zu beschweren. Aber die können ja dir zum Beispiel mal bei Blue Sky folgen. Da bekommt man nämlich was aus Spanien mit. Vielleicht kann man noch mal ein bisschen gucken, was in England so los ist bei manchen Schiedsrichterentscheidungen und nicht wie AA. Eingriffen und so weiter und irgendwelche Koks, einen Schiedsrichter, die ihren Jürgen Klopp hasst, dann im Nachhinein rauslassen. Also vielleicht ist es dann doch alles nicht ganz so schlimm in Deutschland, wie man immer tut.
Also ich halte es für schier ist auch für ziemlich unfähig. Muss man leider so knallhaar sein.
Das ist gar nicht so rausgekommen, Alex.
Die Entscheidung, also wir sprechen bei Tiki Taka im Podcast ja jede Woche drüber und das sind wirklich jetzt hat Fermin Lopez rot gesehen und wurde den Ball wegspitzelt und das ist jeder, der Fußballspiel weiß, das ist keine rote. Aber in der Superzeit, wo du siehst halt kurz das Frame wurde im Follow-Through, der der Fuß so weit oben ist und das sieht halt verzernt aus. Aber und dem Schiedsrichter wurde quasi die vorherige Einstellung gar nicht gezeigt, dass er sieht, dass das eigentlich eine Fußballaktion ist, sondern ihm wird nur das gezeigt, wo der Ball, wo der Fuß da oben ist. Offene Sohle, ja zeigt doch die drei Sekunden vorher, wird ihm nicht gezeigt. Aber dann entscheidet er auf Rot. Aber eine Woche vorher wird ein Papier umgehauen oder zwei und das ist knallrot. Und da geht er nicht mal an den Schiedsrichter, an den Bildschirm der Schiedsrichter. Ja genau, vom VAR. Und das sind so Sachen, wo du dir denkst, jede Woche was anderes und jede Woche wird eine ähnliche Entscheidung komplett anders ausgelegt und mal zeigt er direkt Rot, mal schaltet sich der VAR ein, obwohl er es nicht sollte. Mal schaltet er sich gar nicht ein und du denkst, warum zeigt der ihm das jetzt nicht? Das ist schon, das ist nicht gut, Max, das ist nicht gut.
Ja, ist mir zu generell, aber weißt du, wie oft bin ich auf der Couch bei Günther ja auch schon Millionär geworden. Da krieg ich es auch hin. Die müssen es halt in Sekunden schnell...
Ich hab schon Spiele gepfiffen, Uli, ne?
Ja, ich hab schon Spiele gepfiffen, aber aller Liebe und bei allem...
Ich darf mir das erlauben, wollte ich damit sagen.
Wenn ich nicht die Knieverletzung gehabt hätte, würde ich jetzt auch in La Liga spielen, das wissen wir alle.
Aber allem Respekt, B-Klasse ist nicht...
Ich hab jeden Respekt vor dem Schiedsrichter, aber im Zeitalter von war, musst du den Romero vom Platz stellen, wenn er einen BP von hinten umhaut, weil er ihn nur umhauen will. Und das kann nicht sein, dass ein wahr da stumm bleibt.
Die Frage ist ja aber, wenn Fehler passieren, wie wird damit umgegangen und wenn dann im Nachhinein gesagt wird, ja, das war ein Fehler, dann ist es schon mal viel, viel besser und dann muss man an den Worten dann gemessen werden.
So transparent wird damit nicht umgegangen in Spanien.
Das ist natürlich dann genau ein Team.
Real Madrid hat zum Beispiel die offizielle VAR-Kommunikation angefordert. Die wollten wissen, was hat er besprochen mit dem Schiri. Es wurde ihn verwehrt vom Liga-Verband. Ich glaube auch deswegen haben sie quasi die Worte Manipulation, Bedrug und Verzerrung und Korruption. Oder sich selbst zu schützen. Sind jetzt die Zitate in diesem Brandbrief gewählt, weil eben, ja, weil das so ein System ist, wo man sich selbst schützt. Und ich glaube, das kann man aus der Bundesliga dann schon auch ein bisschen. Gibt es Parallelen, Max? Ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht Schiedsrichterwesen als.
Ja, also Stichwort selbst schützen. Da schütze ich uns jetzt mal selbst und sage, ich finde ich gut. Und wir machen das mal anders. Daniel, was hast du denn noch aus der Ehredivise? Ich hoffe, es sind keine Schiedsrichter-Themen. Bitte, bitte, bitte.
Nee, das hat nichts, sondern einfach noch mal schön zum Abschluss ein MVP und zwar von Diventa. Das schließt so ein bisschen nach und an, dass ich ja gesagt hab auch schon vorhin, dass Oliver Edvardsen jetzt vor einiger Woche zu Allachter gegangen ist. Das heißt, sie brauchen den quasi wie neu ist. Und jetzt wird das Spotlight so ein bisschen verschoben auf Jacob Brolm. Der ist 21 Jahre, ist ein offensiver Mittelfeldspieler, der aber auch gerne mal auf den Flügeln spielt. Und der ist im Prinzip, hat ein ähnliches Skillset eigentlich wie Oliver Edvardsen. Ist sehr triplingstark, ist sehr temporeich und vor allem schafft er es auch unter Druck, die richtigen Entscheidungen schnell zu finden. Also die Entscheidungsfindung ist bei ihm echt stark und kann auch wirklich schöne, öffnende Tabellen spielen. Und das ist so ein bisschen jetzt der MVP von D-Venter jetzt nach Edvardsen-Abgang. Hat in 41 Spielen auch schon acht Tore und fünf Torlagen dabei gesteuert und hat eigentlich auch einen großen Anteil, dass D-Venter auf dem siebten Platz ist. Und bei D-Venter ist es seit einigen Jahren quasi so eine Art Redaktion, dass sie gerne Spiele aus Dänemark, Norwegen, Schweden, Finnland, aus dem Dynamischen Bereich verpflichten. Und vielleicht hat Jakob Reum auch ein bisschen Glück und die große offensive Last eines Edvardsens wird ein bisschen von seinen Schultern genommen, denn sie haben schon wie ein Neues verpflichtet, der ist jetzt 20 Jahre. Das ist Oskar Sievatsen, auch Norweger wie Edvardsen. Und der wurde am Deadline der am dritten, zweiten noch verpflichtet. Und ja, insofern hat Jakob Reum vielleicht doch nicht so die große offensive Last, aber auch Jakob Reum, call ich jetzt auch mal, wird auch nicht mehr allzu lange, denke ich mal, bei Deventer spielen. Der ist auch schon bei einigen Vereinen europäisch offenbar da. Ich habe glaube ich von dem Losinteresse von Merle Bremen gehört, aber ja, ich bin gespannt, was da passiert bei Jakob Reum. Und die Ausbildungsmaschine für Spieler aus den armen Raum, Deventer.
Dementsprechend würde ja dann auch Bremen sehr gut zu Werder passen. Denen sind Dänen ja auch durchaus ein Begriff und erfolgreich. Und jeder, der sich gefragt hat, Deventer, wer war das nochmal? Das waren die Go-Ahead-Eagles. Ich möchte, dass sie nur noch so genannt werden und auch mit dieser Begeisterung. Dann könnt ihr es zuordnen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Haben wir ja neulich drüber gesprochen in der Ligatur. Dann blicken wir nochmal ganz kurz nach Italien, Christian.
Machen wir kurz zwei Worte von mir auch noch zu Warr und Schiedsrichter. Weil Italien geht es auch gerade drunter und drüber. Letzten zwei Spieltage, große Warr-Diskussionen. Da ist das Riesenthema, aber das ist eine eigene Sendung, ist mir klar. Ich glaube, man müsste mal anfragen, anfangen drüber zu reden, über das Warr-Protokoll. Also wann reingehen, wann nicht reingehen. Inter hat gerade ein Tor geschossen nach einer Ecke, die niemals eine Ecke war, weil der Ball schon im Aus war und Tomori ist gerade mit gelber Rot vom Platz geflogen, weil er in den Zweikampf ging, wo abseits davor war. Er geht in den Zweikampf, sieht die zweite gelbe, aber es war ein Abseits. Also das ist ein Riesenthema in Italien. Also es schließt sich da an sehr, sehr schwierige Zeiten. Aber mein letztes Thema wäre, ich hätte, MVP hätte ich Colombo nie mitbringen können. Der hat einfach mal geschmeidigend in den ersten drei Spielen für Juba fünf Tore gemacht. Also der hat sich sehr schnell sehr wohl gefühlt. Und es wird dazu führen, dass Vlaović im Sommer Juwe verlässt. Das können wir dann in Ruhe nochmal quatschen. Also Vlaović sitzt nur noch auf der Bank und kommt rein. Und Juwe wird jetzt alles tun, dass Moa nie dann über den Sommer hinaus dann auch bleiben wird. Aber meine letzte Geschichte ist leider nicht nur schöne, aber passt halt rein und dürfen wir dann halt auch nicht untergehen lassen. Mois Ken spielt eine herausragende Saison, hat unter der Woche gegen, das war dieses emotional aufgeladene Nachholspiel gegen Inter, das ja damals abgebrochen wurde, weil Eduardo Bove auf dem Feld zusammengebrochen ist. Da waren noch 70 Minuten offen, es stand eben 0-0. Und das hat die Fiorentina zu Hause 3 zu 0 gegen Inter gewonnen. Doppelpackt von Ken. Das war wirklich ein unfassbar emotionales Spiel. Drei Tage später kam es schon zum Rückspiel in San Siro. Das hat dann Inter gewonnen, aber leider ist es keine sportliche Geschichte, denn nach diesem Spiel ist Mois Ken auf sozialen Netzwerken massiv rassistisch beleidigt worden und er hat das Ganze öffentlich gemacht. Er hat jeden einzelnen rassistischen Beleidigungen sozusagen gescreenshotted, hat die veröffentlicht und hat zusammen mit dem Club, mit der Fiorentina, die haben jeden dieser einzelnen Beleidigungen angezeigt. Und das, glaube ich, ist das Entscheidende. Sein Kommentar war, war schlimm, dass es das im Jahr 2025 noch gibt. Ich glaube, wir haben öfter hier schon gesprochen. Es tut weh, jedes Mal nochmal darüber sprechen zu müssen, aber so ist es anscheinend. Ich wollte die Geschichte jetzt mitbringen, dass ich es stark von ihm fand und stark von der Fiorentina, dass sie eben nicht nur symbolisch agiert haben, sondern wirklich hier jeden einzelnen angezeigt haben. Und jetzt geht es halt einfach drum. Ich meine, das ist eine gesellschaftliche Diskussion. Die hat ja nicht nur mit dem Fußball zu tun. Das betrifft ja andere Menschen, die in der Öffentlichkeit stehen. Leider auch. Jetzt geht halt zumindest, finde ich, der Finger auf die Autoritäten. Jetzt müsste man dann halt irgendwann auch mal Wege finden, um Menschen, die sowas von sich geben, dann halt auch ordentlich zu, juristisch zu verfolgen. Und ja, das juristische Ding, sie spüren zu lassen. Deswegen Respekt an Ken, weil ich finde, man kann da keinem vorschreiben, wie man mit sowas umgeht. Auch wenn jemand anders das anders lösen möchte, nicht in die Öffentlichkeit geht, glaube ich, muss man da auch höchsten Respekt haben. Aber Ken hat es so gemacht, ist ja schon vielleicht, erinnere ich noch ein paar in sehr jungen Jahren bei Juve, ich glaube damals war er 17, ist er auch schon mal in Kaljarit bei einem Auswärtsspiel von den Rängen rassistisch beleidigt worden. Da ist er auch Richtung Kurve hin, hat sozusagen die Auseinandersetzung gesucht. Also Ken ist da einer, der das, wie soll man sagen, auch öffentlich transportiert. Und ja, die Hoffnung ist, dass da sich was tut. Aber wir wissen leider alle, glaube ich, dass es solche Geschichten hat schon oft gegeben hat. Ich habe logisch auch kein Rezept, aber ich wollte es hervorheben, dass stark wie die Fiorentine und Ken damit umgegangen sind.
Aber wirklich. Und das bringt uns zum Ende dieser Sendung. Ich mach's ganz schnell. Ich danke euch vielen sehr, sehr herzlich. Ich danke auch denjenigen, die diese Sendung hier ermöglicht haben. Unter anderem Robin, JJ1860, RobertS04, Elch, BigJu und Dodge. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Alles, was wir hier machen, ist Paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei von euch finanziert. rasenfunk.de und dann auf den Unterstützen-Button klicken und auch sehr gerne unsere anderen Formate abonnieren. Wir sprechen über die Bundesliga der Männer, der Frauen. Wir sprechen über Nationalteams und alle Länderspiele der deutschen Teams. Und es gibt auch neue Tribüngespräche zu dem Polizeikostenurteil. Macht's gut, bis bald, ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!